hey guys welcome to the show I just want
to say uh it's a pleasure to be your
host we have a great show planned today
last night we left the rler talk even
was getting red Up by Baby gr he said
that was so
and even K and I show speed hitting the
gritty a gming
fornite a grim shaking
fortnite yes so
anyway today the much anticipated potato
battle The Gauntlet was
thrown as we talk as
we okay okay
excitement um the gaunt was thrown as we
were discussing in Thanksgiving uh it
got heated people said my potatoes are
the best others said no come that heat
potatoes are the
best and so we have
decided for your viewing pleasure to
have a competition today heat there will
be
four
chefs and four judges I'm the meat Chef
each dish will be presented
uh
anonymously it's a blind taste test as
you guys
know uh what do they call them
randomized blind trials that's how we do
it that's the real scientific method
it's just like that it's the real
scientific method you
know and so the four judges are going to
sit here and deliberate we have them all
set up here you can show the empty table
yep and they will great they will each
wow throw up a rating thanks for letting
us bump up the budget for the background
by the way yeah you know I I always
spring for the show
man oh I spoked you soon hold on who yo
I didn't pay for that who licensed that
image okay all right good we'll cut that
out so basically somebody is heating up
the potatoes at this moment no not
somebody Sam I wasn't sure if I should
who who is Sam who's Sam She Sam is
heating up the potatoes and we will go
one by one a first one should be ready
fairly soon Sam Temple thank the gifted
that's what I hear but it's all very
uh it's all very
exciting I want to say here at the top
but we have so much other fun stuff uh
uh I want to say happy birthday to Howe
mandelle it's his birthday today oh
really yeah we love him how old is he
today he's 67 I believe really yeah
sounds show
us
68 he doesn't look a day past he looks
[__] he looks so good3 how do you do
that Howie is it all the keeping the
germs awake makes you look so young
nothing oh oh just nothing nothing it
was
nothing bad for
plants
so we love Howe and I just wanted to say
happy birthday to him that's all
um also so we have put together some
great segments here we've got the have
you all been following this
Enrique Enrique and glacius did I say
his name right yep mm trying to find it
in the where is it in the document what
number is that goof and he's in the
Goofs and GFF section so he's been I
guess having accusations that he can't
sing for a long time and there was some
recent clips that came out thank you
Lena that um that
really drove that point home and so we
go back in time and we have a tons of
Clips actually five here or
six there were a whole history of
Enrique and glacius not being able to
sing which is very funny I I've been
very uh familiar with this uh situation
for quite some time now and I'm happy
it's coming back to light so what's the
accusation that he didn't sing it or
that cuz he was singing before autotune
I feel like he was and I I think that
was his problem but then what about the
studio recording it sounds good it
doctor it up doctored it up doctored it
up even before they had the technology
it's possible or he just took it take by
take to hit the key properly that's true
um you could just go take by take yeah
yeah um but yeah it's uh it's been a
long uh long known thing so it's not a
Millie vanilla thing no he's actually
singing and some good context too is
that his father is a very famous singer
as well that is interesting and and he
wrote his music is that the presumption
uh I'm I'm sure he's had right
songwriters I mean that's a very common
thing cuz if he wrote the music and he
just can't sing that good I'm I'm not
going to I'm not going to [__] on him
for all that that being said it is funny
and that's why we're watching
it you know I remember when he he's gay
right I remember when he came out I I
have a memory of him coming out and
being a big deal that's Ricky Year Ricky
Martin
yeah anyway live in the v Loca baby wait
who's RI now I'm confused who's Ricky
Martin it's very easy to get them mixed
up yeah they're popular at the same time
so okay Ricky Martin who's this guy I am
gay so Ricky Martin is gay
and we love that about him don't we love
okay okay okay do okay no homo and how's
his voice Ricky's the goat yeah it's
really good he was on an episode of
Glee he was oh then he's got to be he's
got to be really good yeah yeah so Ricky
Martin we love him are they both Puerto
Rican and then
Enrique I see he's Puerto Rican
glacius um is it okay if I type is Roo
glacius gay
R don't do
it yeah don't do it though don't ask
Google that yeah ask go why can't I ask
CU I feel like would Google doesn't know
the ins and the outs of the feelings you
know what I mean so who is gay I guess
hold on one sec here why W this come off
the screen what the [__] he was born in
Spain oh he's okay interesting
Spanish uh there's something up with my
computer Dan it's not
is Dan here he's um fixing something
else okay I'll I'll Google it off screen
no I'm good I'm good I got it so
apparently
guys uh Enrique has actually been
married to uh tennis player Anna cornova
they've actually uh have a son and a
daughter so we love that oh they're
twins as well so how how about that
that's wonderful very good that's
wonderful um
so that's it I guess we can do that now
I mean as we wait for the
potatoes but maybe we'll do shorter
things I already set it up though what
do you think love the potato or the the
Enrique thing should I do it now or wait
[__] it de you never know when the
potatoes are here they got to be heated
up properly do it live all right so
let's do it then Enrique my
boy um first this audio came out from a
recent concert and a lot of people
couldn't even believe that it
was that it was real um not it's not
just bad it's
like it's just another planet I mean
it's like the worst singing G I've ever
heard in my life yeah it's it's not that
bad like he's worse than like the Goof
singers on American
Idol listen to
this
oh my
[Music]
God this man is on a
stage in front of people is is it
possible to give them the benefit of the
doubt Zach maybe you can tell me if
you're singing into autotune would you
ever intentionally sing like that I mean
if you can't sing yeah okay but you
wouldn't if you're a decent singer would
you ever sing like that in the autotune
for any reason I don't think so I think
you would be trying to hit it as you
want to sing well still Dan and I had a
theory that he pissed off his monitor
guy and he like uh they just totally
pushed him up in the mix and dropped the
autotune out God but that's got to be
really bad for that audio guy's
career like that is not not I don't
think many people are going to want to
hire him after that he might have been
having a bad night I just to give him
the benefit of it out but this has
happened on multiple occasions where
it's like okay maybe this guy can't
really sing that way but I I mean
like you know when have you ever heard
anybody sing like that
ever those dog [__] performances on
American Idol you nailed
it yeah but this is like the worst of
the
[Music]
worst dude I mean I mean and then so
that same concert though unrelated to
his singing a really funny clip came out
of him humping the stage age uh and a
sexual uh a sexual dance in the the
words of Rudy sexual dance it's a sexual
dance check this out you
guys was this a Enrique Enrique concert
or was it like
a it it's he's the main line he's on a
big tour right now with I believe
Pitbull oh oh sounds [__] fun wait is
he opening for pit uh I believe the tour
is called the Trilogy tour it is the
trilogy tour Pitbull Ricky Martin holy
[__] and Rick glaas big three man
oh damn pit would never get caught like
this no those are I mean two Heavy
Hitters Ricky Martin and pit I mean [__]
dude doll Mr
worldwide so wait what am I I didn't
even know what I'm looking at here oh
that's his head okay wow why are you
doing that that's just weird it's just
weird man uh but here here's a closer
look for you guys at home here he is
here's his head he's just humping the
stage that's it that's what he's doing
oh you could see it here I didn't even
realize you could see it big on the
Monitor and it's a sexual dance dude
somebody what are you doing bro he could
have been drunk off his ass said [__]
it yeah that would explain still
probably if you're doing a show for like
I don't know thousands of paying 10,000
paying people you know somewhere else he
thinks he's in bed somewhere yeah he was
just totally transported literally so
that's the recent one that got everyone
talking about it but now that I got
tickled by the the
Enrique uh
feather we started to look back at some
of the other Great Clips here he is on
Howard Stern back in 2000 this is at the
height of his popularity I
believe um what sparked Enrique to go on
Howard was a t a tape of him horribly
singing back in
2000 Howard took it and ran with it
showing it to everyone en Ricky was on
tour and flew to New York to prove to
Howard that he could in fact sing here's
the original one that uh he was trying
to disprove this was like play on his
radio this was like his Howie prolapse
version I guess comparison he was
showing it to everyone wow okay wow show
back in the year
2000 all I
need the RM divice
Lo in the music your heart will be mine
all I
need in your
eyes you
be get out this feeling
forever together nothing matters just
you and the
night taking
you
worse than anyone I've ever been in a
musical in my whole life childhood this
is what I'm like at karaoke and it's why
I don't do
karaoke the story okay that was iconic
holy [__] we got to sound bite that up I
again I I've known about that clip for
years now I'm so I'm so happy this is
coming to light I have never seen that
yeah it's uh wow it's
pretty I mean it is inspiring like if he
can be a singer
you
know his dad's Julio glacius he's a
legend he's like his dad's a big deal
yeah very big deal I guess the singing
Talent didn't yeah he didn't get that
Jee that's a straight nepo yeah musician
right there well anyway here's the clip
on of him performing on Howard Stern
after being uh I guess called out I
don't know if that's the right word but
goofed on so the story is that um
Enrique was on tour I believe he was in
Italy and he put everything aside and
went went to stern to prove him wrong I
mean that's kind of like a that's like a
that's a baller move totally and he's
like [__] it I'm going to go show
everyone I can't sing yeah and it took
balls balls of steel yeah oh you can
update the thumbnail by the way Dan with
the one cam say okay yeah thank you I
love delusional
confidence I mean where would we be
without it yeah I know where would I be
without it I wouldn't I'd be single
without delusional confidence trust me
trust
me uh but anyway here's Enrique
oh [__] godamn you Instagram sing to
[Music]
me wow well you can sing you can say we
got we got to what is that honey what
what was that I it up you know you know
can we can we do another can we do
another he can sing right Robin he sang
that song he sing that
song it's a lukewarm Rec he's saying
that song he's saying it how did Howard
receive that if you're I don't know if
you're up to date on all that what do
you mean like uh was it settled he's
like okay can you sing or what did it
raise more questions no I I think it was
put to bed quote unquote it was a nice
gesture you know I thought on Enrique's
part yeah definitely even to show up and
do like
this your eyes I mean it's not as bad no
definitely not I think it's just that
high note he's just struggling the [__]
out of it's decent here it's decent yeah
and he's trying okay I mean no right
okay I mean it's better than the last
one his tone is insane okay it's jarring
okay let me say this then it's better
than the last two clips we saw yeah so
Improvement that's amazing people are
saying he's hot so it's all good yeah
true that is something I don't have uh
but uh I do have delusional confidence
so that's
Enrique uh but we have more actually
here's he he's okay he's a Serial ground
Humper he's done this
before uh let's take a listen and a
look wait is this the okay is this the
same show yeah I think it's a different
uh frame okay I like this angle
though Enrique you're married man you
got kids
wait what is he
reenacting I think he's just plastered
bro but what the [__] was that he didn't
even do any thrusting it was like the
most half-ass it looks like he just
needed a
break like what the [__] hold
[Music]
on what is that
dude he he's reenacting a real sex uh he
finished in 3 seconds he's a one pump
jump that's it that's all he got
[Music]
in wow he has a lot of fans still
though
[Music]
okay Enrique we love you man look at all
these fans dude holy [__] these people
came from from Enrique we love Puerto we
love Puerto Rico we love Puerto R and
Spain
honestly I go to that concert you [__]
with pitbull all three of them who's the
third Ricky Ricky Martin oh Ricky was
there yeah yeah oh [__] I didn't know
Ricky was there the Holy Trinity brother
the trilogy tour so Pitbull's Puerto
Rican
right oh Cuban okay so it's it's 305
nice there you go all representing
different
uh different
turfs it is truly internal ational it is
um here is another one with Worldwide
here's a big one on Tik Tok that's been
going around of him singing from a
different
show he always dresses the same I kind
of vibe with
that I like his
look let's
see
[Music]
what can he hear himself that's what I'm
thinking that it's guy was [__] with
him I feel like somebody on his audio
team is mad they but that's would ruin
their career they would never work maybe
he's really mad I this is so
embarrassing so he in his ears he must
have sounded either he couldn't hear
himself or he sounded fine or he could
have just been drunk off his
ass this is next level
man and he's I like that he's up there
like he's really
serving like he's
[Music]
really
B players trying to save the
show so I was thinking this might be an
inspiring story about how if he can do
it anyone can but actually it's like a
really depressing nepotism Story
Probably where if you're so this
talentless you can have a monster career
failing upwards written by Ryan
Kavanaugh forward by Ryan Kavanaugh
right
he had he had a mole on his face that he
had removed and like everyone was making
fun of it for years chat was saying that
his talent was in the mole when you
remove that could be though that is a
theory and then there's one more and
then we'll start the
potatoes um potatoes shout out Enrique
we love you man this is all for fun
see wait hold on POV waited a lifetime
to see Enrique sing just to find out he
sounds like Elmo can't
say yeah hold on imagine you're actually
a huge fan and you're just like huh
yeah it's
karaoke
yeah what is he
[Music]
doing how much do you think you got paid
for the show a lot of
at
least probably probably if it's his show
it's like some William Hung [__] dude
like oh William Hung was a much W
thought of that name William Hung was
not bad no like he's not a bad singer
better than [__] Enrique Bro [__]
yeah hell yeah probably a lot more
affordable to see him in in live
too so that's just my he still doing his
thing William I think he's on a cameo
still on Cameo oh interesting probably
kills it on there pull that up let me
watch a few of his wonder what he gets
up to Sam you can start bringing out the
the the first
round uh well then hold on the judges
need to
migrate or just if you want to send me a
link I got I got the link and then
youall want to the judges can come sit
okay thank
you all right everybody Welcome to The
Great Potato cook off of
we have four contestants and four judges
the four contestants are Sam
myself
Zachary and Mr
lovely Mr love
wide uh the judges will be joining us up
here please uh love you're sitting up
here right no just the judges up there
why you take a she right sorry my bad so
we're missing oh Dan I guess wait why
you take a SE right over there in the
meantime let's enjoy some William Hong
uh Cameo kids week what does that mean
they're selling kid
cameos oh it's like cartoons that's sick
bippy wait hold on yeah they're having a
sale on kid cameos but are they really
selling me wait they're selling messages
from kids that's creepy colors ccope
City oh it's AR I'm so excited to be
able to send personalized mess that is
so weird holy [__] that's an AI voice
Sesame yeah that was I I agree what's
what's Elmo up to Sesame Street really
sanctioned this
Elmo Elmo is so excited to play with
youque
glaces why would they do that baby shark
I mean what the hell this is weird man
Ryan's toy reveiew let's see oh they're
all just com oh I think okay I'm very
excited to be able to send personalized
messages to you your friends or any of
your family members [__] that is weird
so this is what happened they reached
out to all these people and they're like
I know it's weird to have a kid do this
so we're going to AI their voice and
then you just get passive income in
truth it doesn't look like anyone's
buying these and it's just really creepy
and
weird well okay good stuff I didn't get
to look at William Hung
yet um let me just watch one real fast
William Hong and you probably can they
see Ian proba know okay cool from
American Idol as the Sheep bangs guy
hell yeah whether it's to send digital
Christmas cards invite friends to your
party or surprise someone for Christmas
I'm here for all the festive fun through
personal video messages the best news
love Willam I wonder if we could do
something with him like genuinely I do
love him I think his energy is
infectious I think he's actually not
he's a pretty decent singer too did you
see uh what mus the note I dropped he he
was a he was a f no I didn't should I
check that first before I go on he's
local oh
he's he bought his he brought his career
as a musician to an end in 2011 he
accepted a job opportunity as a
technical crime analysist whoa at the LA
Sheriff's department and decided to
pursue law enforcement yo William Hung
is a [__]
bro no but he I like the um technical
crime analysis that's cool yeah that's
really cool yeah that's like Dexter [__]
I think right famously good guy the good
guy famously good guy Dexter yeah um
nothing weird about him William Hong was
he was one of these contestants
that he wasn't like good quote but
everybody loved him everybody loved and
he became like this National celebrity
for a while for a couple years even yeah
so anyway pre uh pre- interet memes well
I guess the internet was around but
smelling good in here Danielle this is
let's see this William Hong
congratulations on getting married I
want to wish you both a long and happy
marriage here is a song for you and Can
You Feel the Love Tonight oh pretty good
it is where we are that's not bad yeah
it's better
than W the the very bad you can hold the
tong well we should I genuinely would
like can we reach out to him maybe I
don't know I'd love to collaborate with
him what what do you want to do with
William just talk to him first of all
just want and we'll start there and then
probably we can work on some music
together or
something but I'd love just to connect
with him I find that so it's so cool cuz
like at the time I was just some kid and
he was like this International CB and
I'm thinking now like oh my God we might
be able to
actually with enri how old were we when
that all happened I feel like I was in
like middle school or something yeah
like sixth grade he looks really good by
the way he has an age today yeah all
right let's get into the potato off we
have first contestant all right it looks
like now we're not are you judging I
don't know wait yeah we figured if she's
doing it Jud yeah I gave her a I'm a
contestant yes but it looks like we have
here a pretty standard Fair of um mashed
potatoes I think are we seeing the
closeup Ian sorry we can't see okay
wow mhm these are special
potatoes very good M why you looking at
me and saying that I really like it I
don't know I ooh this is the host I'm
talking to that's good good
nice H I'm starting to get a feeling I
know who these
are that's
nice I don't know who made these they're
quite good very good
nice you want tell me about the flavor
profiles tell me what's going on in your
mouths H yeah how do you describe it
it's like the
softness that is in mashed potatoes but
it has like a mhm not like cheese but it
has there's a savoriness to it
yeah yeahmy and it's there's a little
bit of a Umami to it it has um some
chunks in it's almost like a but they're
soft it's like soft serve ice cream
interesting very similar texture very
interesting in a good way that's I'm
saying that in a good way well that's
nice for whoever made
these I love
it um you want to finish mine what else
could I say about this and those those
ain't diet those ain't diet friendly you
know what I I'm not big into cooking and
I'm definitely haven't watched a lot of
cooking shows but one that I did used to
watch quite a bit of was Iron Chef back
in the
day both the the original and the
American remake and um there was this
one Chef or not Chef uh one of the
judges that was frequently on there and
it used to crack me up it became like a
meme with who I was watching with
because
every single Dish everything had a
little too much or too little acidity
there's not enough acidity and it was
like you don't even know what you're
saying dude like that's the only thing
that you know to say about food and
you're just busting that out at every
opportunity I wish it' had a little more
acidity just a little bit more chef and
they always talk about that too I've
never thought about that in my life and
somehow but what do they more citric
acid like what does they say more lemon
juice like I get it acidity can do a lot
to a dish or whatever are they just
saying lemon juice what does that I
guess probably in most cases yeah what
else qualifies asthetic food would
vinegar vinegar like more vinegar tomato
is that is V I don't even know if it's
acidic probably whatever gives you
heartburn anything that gives you
heartburn um so anything I eat category
level of acidity hey hold on what what
is an acidic it's too acidic food just a
little more acidic let's see citrus
fruits obviously that's the obvious one
and that's pretty much all it says you
know that's it I'm seeing if the chat
knows it opens up the flavor says
somebody yeah I mean I get it I get that
it like it is important to cooking but
it did just seem like that guy that was
the one fact that guy learned about
cooking but I know they use it a lot cuz
I tell you in Top Chef they always talk
about that okay at the same time not
every dish needs lemon juice
right right you know what I mean like
not always time in a place so if you
guys want to go Sam's ready with the
next batch should we write down our
score so where did a go how do we do the
score out of 10 and it out we're going
to do like it's like the NBA dunk
contest Olympics at you can do points as
well you can do like eight point
whatever oh interesting yeah make the
math real hard on maybe we shouldn't do
that yeah let's keep it round numers to
keep generator so you could do whatever
you want Oh do whatever you want okay
fno you have a what I have like a I have
a calculator
open all right so everybody yes I see
everybody warning me about the duck fat
in Sam's that's been accounted for it's
it's all good there there are vegetarian
options being presented eded in
somewhere in the we've thought about it
so um okay so deliberate think think to
your guys s here and U do we keep it to
ourselves or no well we're going to
reveal it we'll reveal it okay so is
everybody ready I'm really debating this
cuz I'm on the fence between two choices
here take your time I guess we can do
points I I should just full points
yeah or whatever you want Dan you're the
judge you're the you determine your own
fate here today okay all right whatever
you want so it looks like the verdict is
in so let's go ahead judges and flip
it oh I did it kind of small okay so
Lena gives me an Lena gave an 8.5 8.5
Olivia gave an eight AB gave a 10 I love
that about you
AB did you did you love it that much or
were you just being are you just trying
to oh oh this God why would you do
that why would you do that you gave me
the lowest rating of anyone on the panel
I'm sorry I'm sorry his rating has a c
what made you think that that would be
funny I got Dan well him being mad about
it is what's getting me I guess the the
conflux of it all yeah a generous rating
and Ela gave a 10 and is that because
it's me El or is it because you love it
I truly love it thank you I was
considering a 10 but I'm like it's the
first I know it's a little hard yeah if
better you got to leave yourself some
headro that's fair it's we're setting
the I would almost gave it a nine I was
on the fence and I then I remembered we
could do decimals so thank you thank you
guys I mean overall pretty shame on you
a doesn't know anything that just being
honest I'm sorry damn I'm kidding I'm
you weren't even supposed to know that
was the whole point yeah yeah come here
thank you for
that actually
10 too late I'm just okay excellent well
I'm excited to keepa potatoes round
coming up and I'm very excited to try
these cuz these a m and I don't know
who's whoa they're like potato chips
yeah y love pot chips so these are what
I like to refer to as potato
medallions huh oh those look good glassy
super thin huh really
good you get a good shot like this this
looks so good is this
effectively just a potato chip almost
it's it's just like a like a homemade
potato chip essentially it's a potato
chip plus okay which that's that's fine
by me you all know
texture wow
M that's pretty fun it's a nice side
dish I can see it mix absolutely good
Smokey flavor you could dip it like a
potato chip dip
it oo that one was real crispy I liked
it even more when it was crispy really I
like it when it's a little soft in
yeah nice
seasoning yeah subtle I could use a
little more acidity in my opinion it's
quite good Sal personally salt yes yeah
something taste it's missing a little
but I like it good texture yeah I mean I
I like my food salty so I wasn't going
to say that but a dash more seasoning
perhaps right but I mean tastes great
mhm that was very good very good okay
okay I have my rating so the judges are
uh deliberating they're going
to
the to the scoreboards they're
conferring Dan and ab are talking uh
quite
intently the girls are
chatting very good I love those I would
be I would be thrilled to get those
served me anywhere any time I agree y be
very happy everybody got their scores M
and when you guys are ready if you could
say the scores one by one for just audio
as well good idea oh great call uh why
don't we just do it one by one start
with Lena go ahead Lena I say seven
seven I say eight eight I say eight
another eight I also said eight wow what
I said 9.8 oh wow and I just put a
little salt a little more salt that he
didn't take much off that was a perfect
score nearly I loved it if there was a
couple more Flakes I'm with you it was
great
fantastic I mean e with FR I'm also
hungry yeah right right right if I if I
was going to rate those because I'm not
a judge but I would definitely give that
like eight and a half nine it was very
good mhm
mhm okay it looks like Sam's here with
the next too all right third contestant
here oh this is my [__] you like these
steak fries I love these steak fries
these are kind of like a roasted potato
situation I have have a problem with the
steak fries really it it it's the thing
is like it's easy to [__] up cuz it
needs to be crispy and pillowy and times
people don't cook that [__] through very
very true this looks good has an
interesting texture thank
you okay M so we got a nice shot of that
ooh beautiful wow
so good
who good
execution I like the seasoning mhm
seasoned nicely nice seasoning it's not
just salt there's something else in
there little paprika or something
mhm I have to try the second one before
before I make a call here I did that too
yeah I had
to test the uh consistency of flavor
the first one I had a complaint like you
were just saying it's hard to it wasn't
crispy enough on the Outside Inside was
okay but too soft on the outside this
one nailed it this is nice and crispy on
the outside pillowy on the inside this
would be great with ketchup mhm mhm some
red corn syrup baby he going for all of
this I love it it's like a crispy skin
but also soft inside so good you're so
right yeah
all right the judges have uh you want to
finish it you here go
ahead I'm just
thinking okay so the judges have
returned to their white boards to Del
liberate to settle the Fate what of all
the potato contestants here today and
there's so much on the line uh and we
honor all contestants everyone who
enters the arena
uh wins in the heart and minds of the
people judges ready ready I think so
Elena go ahead 10 oh [__] 10 10 W 10
seriously wa 9.9 you would knocked it a
couple points or one point for um that
first one just the outside not being
crispy enough but the second one made up
for it and I did 9.85 wow that's a
perfect potato that's a clear front
runner here so I personally it's not my
thing I don't like it because no it was
good it was very good I give it like an
eight again probably very good
but I think my thing the fry the crunchy
to soft ratio it's not a good balance
there's too much soft and not enough
crunchy I think that's why I knocked the
points for consistency maybe it would
have been fair to be a little bit lower
than this because again the the first
fry I had was probably an 8.5 the second
fry I had was a 10 well also to fair to
the if they were all like that second
one it would be clear T mine was good
like it was crunchy on the outside and
soft inside to be fair Chef it was
reheated and
that yeah because everybody made
home that's true I made mine this
morning I I think everyone
did
yeah okay wow
people are
loving this is the best dude I love
potatoes man it's just all about it what
a great potato the hell of a thing huh
I'm yell you're jealous yeah I want food
too yeah we don't have enough well not s
Go I mean I made enough for everybody
yeah I'll get some after after we'll get
seconds yeah uh can I have some after no
camera shut up cam cam you can help
yourself go ahead you guys are not Tough
Enough I mean I like your guys's rating
too why not well you cooked cam right no
you didn't I dropped out there's a lot
of lot of things going on already to
play all this oh you dropped out yeah I
dropped out last minute uh injury yeah
my potatoing
hand how
many four four people yeah young
Zachariah is somewhere on here wow I've
never had something that zook oh very
interesting comes contestant number
three h interesting situation looks like
lots of herbs on there I love herbs very
Herby love jellyfish in
her who who was that excc EXC jellyfish
yeah he asked if jellyfish was an herb
really God made
herb I mean maybe [__] I haven't thought
about it before is it I don't believe so
now kind
of I'd say it's a Grace SP well well
who's to say really at the end of the
day what is the
herb and what isn't thank you Sam so
let's take a look here at contestant
number
three we're featuring a n almost like a
potato lotka right style thin
smashed soft in the middle he's always
got that one ready to go Zach you're a
little too fast with that buddy if you
weren't Jewish would be a problem right
Shalom
brother but so so soft in the middle
crunchy
soy M
interesting that Rosemary that
Rosemary
interesting
yeah the potato is seasoned with
something unusual or they've captured
some kind of flavors in
there it's got nice soft outside crunchy
on the out you know it's got the skin on
right is that skin
on just a oh yeah I think it is yeah no
I think it's skin on yeah this is
good 's A little seasoning but again I'm
a salty boy mm true salt I could use
more salt on this as well
but but at least everything is so good
yeah I can say impressive so far
yeah not bad man how close to lockas are
hash browns like not at
all I don't know there's a lot of
different kinds of hash browns laa is
basically just a potato
pancake it's way denser it's got egg and
flour in it it's like a
little right that I think that's
hamburger patio right
right damn and boy are they good I got
to say I don't know cuz the competition
is tough mhm everybody's really good
damn so the third contestant everybody
uh
judges judges are
considering all the options oo
Dan is tortured over this this tough
tough
decision jack it off somebody gifted uh
20 memberships by the way CH
Chas thank you Chas oh thank you so much
thank you for calling that out too Dan I
hate to miss them
um David thank you for the Dono it's
just potato emojis we love that about
you very good that was that was the
toughest one you to rate yeah this is a
hard one I really liked it I just feel a
little overwhelmed by the oil or
whatever it's cooking or like butter
there's something kind of like yeah it's
the only one can I give M I don't want
to I don't want to uh Poison the Well
well I think we've all written our scor
so it's the only one I didn't finish and
I think it's
because well I've eaten a lot of
potatoes already not part of it but also
[Music]
because it's it's it's a little oily and
it's a little and for my taste a little
under seasoned mhm agree okay well let's
start with Lena again seven give it a
seven good score
7.5 nine for ab nine for me eight oh
eight for mea okay good range ad you
really hated my potatoes H you know what
it didn't it didn't taste as unhealthy
as the other ones and I like like really
unhealthy food I like that one's got to
be the most unhealthy bro yeah I don't
know this yours this last one feels very
Bary my Mash p is like 50% butter and
cream cheese yours tasted too pure
interesting which is which was a good
thing but yeah I need some nasty
interesting I really like this one I I
only I was debating between a 10 and a
nine really um personally uh the reason
I knocked it was the same reason you
stated I do wish it was had more salt
yeah um I did really like the herb
seasoning a lot though and I feel like
that with some salt would have
definitely knocked it up to a 10 I think
little skin was a nice I love that it is
nice I don't mind that it was so oily
personally like I I just accepted that
I'm eating an oily ass potato right now
and that's okay cold it is again worth
remembering
memory
remembering that uh this is being rehe
mhm true and this is a fried item yeah
very
true that's true so uh congratulations
excuse
me Cass says there's more I went to a
pit concert on a random one off and it
was the most wild experience man did an
entire America tribute for 10 minutes
hell yeah Pito loves America he sure
does um somebody uh somebody here has
been to a Pitbull concert right really
oh it's Sam that's right at the time of
my life oh yeah she's a pit fan I forgot
yeah yeah was it really good so fun he
he's a performer right like that man
puts on a show yeah it was it was really
really good actually oh my goodness so
this is this definitely has sweet potato
in it which right is not potato to be
clear right but is it mixed in W uh
right I mean it's yeah it's a uh a
squash right sweet potato isn't it
essentially the same thing yeah or a a
gourd or something am I potato is not a
potato uh I mean like all vegetables
it's all kind of they're not it's not a
well here let's see it
grows sweet oh it's a root root
vegetable uh Ro still to me Dam so
they're both Roots starchy tuous not
actually related how interesting is that
both the potato and sweet potato
originated from Central and South
America they are actually not related
they come from different families with
potato coming from The Nightshade and
the sweet potato coming from Morning
Glory family who put potato in the title
then how interesting well I mean I get
it they seem similar it's hard to
imagine that you know nature produced
two so similar looking things that
aren't
related happens a lot though right
Darwin uh talked about that convergence
convergent evolution I think is what
it's
called the big example of that is how uh
I I believe that over uh the history of
evolution on Earth crabs have emerged
like dozens and dozens of different
times like totally unrelated but like
they wind up being crab like creatures
that's that makes me wonder if on alien
planets that host
life how similar it would end up to what
we know as life because if there it's
just I mean the natural order of things
is the same there as it is here yeah I
mean unless it's got like a different
atmosphere atmosphere could affect
things a lot yeah but if it's like a
watery planet earthlike planet you know
maybe there's me out there um saying
this at the exact same time is yam and
sweet potato the same thing yes hold on
or not the same thing necessarily but
they're they're those are more related
than potatoes this says myth sweet
potatoes are yams that's a myth
apparently that's a myth that's what
this says here I I didn't well I don't
think that they are yams but I thought
they were more closely related than uh
everyone try it no not yet I have not
tried it
interesting I'll say visually not the
most looks like baby food a little bit
palatable but that's okay that's what I
was going to say it reminds me of baby
food yeah and like when my sister is
trying to feed her baby but she keeps
spitting it out because they don't like
the veggies but yeah they're good though
yeah I know they are good actually
tastes good nice it's a nice kind of
pudding sweet mhm very Savory mhm could
use a little more acidity little
more oh yeah I wanted to thank still as
you guys consider the it's almost like
too soft that Mak
sense yeah e yeah I feel you I want to
say thank tiny thank you for the five
gifted love you thank you Jacob's proud
Madre we love you Mom thank you for the
10 gift
dude
[Music]
um Mom sorry I hit them all
uh all right
so some did you see the one where they
asked you to dance no oh well somebody
donated $10 and say we we get an Ethan
dance at some
point I oh no I guess not I don't know
I'll work it in I'll work it in I just
don't feel like standing up right now
for no yeah you know maybe not right now
they said at some point so I don't know
oh jeez
said not right
now can't do
it all right even oh yeah I got to rate
these uh sweet so this is the fourth
entry the final entry in fact we have um
the first entry that's not purely a
potato little
different little
orange indicating the presence of sweet
potato or yam
honestly I think maybe adding sweet
potato was a risk because while it's
healthier maybe I think potato is
superior you you stick with the OG yeah
old I mean because nobody wants sweet
potato fries they just get them because
they're like maybe it's a little
sometimes you think maybe it's a little
healthier sometimes sweet potato fries
can really hit I don't know would you
get sweet potato fries I go for sweet
potato fries sometimes yeah
it's like um it's like onion rings like
sometimes like you you go and you want
to switch it up a little bit I don't get
onion rings very often but sometimes I'm
like I'll at the onion rings this time I
like onion rings well the onion rings
aren't trying to be healthy though yeah
that's true but just in the sense of
like I don't feel like the nor you know
I'm always having the standard fries let
me let's do some sweet potato fries this
time I didn't know sweet potato fries
were healthy or I mean it's probably
it's still fried so depends how it's
prepared I mean if it's deep it's
probably better than potato either way
you make it though maybe yeah I think
psychologically it feels
better all right okay are we ready this
is the fourth contestant judges uh Lena
um I did six a six oh did 7.5 okay 7.5
7.5 6.5 6.5 for I did 7.5 as well and
seven and seven okay I think that that
sounds like it averages to seven the
people have
spoken still very good didn't didn't
blow my socks off like some of the
others and so now that all the votes are
in in the back we will have Ian
triangulate the numbers and present us
from bottom to
top the order uh we have super computers
crunching in the
back um we have the best and brightest
Minds currently working on the averages
I'm sorry da I'm afraid I can't do that
the square roots are being calculated
the circumference I'm afraid I can't do
that the
diameter it's all happening backstage
and
um and uh we actually have the same
mathematician that dream hired to prove
he didn't cheat calculating in the back
I'm going to need I'm going to need an
essay from him about why I didn't
win zucchini fries okay zucchini fries
are always good those are good like and
I you know those I love those you dip
that [__] in ranch [__] it those are
so good and I believe there's some uh
bonus uh bacon potatoes that are
currently being made as well bonus dish
sound amazing my God wait dan you ate
all four of them was there no duck fat
one uh she had made an alternative
vegetarian one and assured me that I
would be served that one nice wow and I
was said well I I TR yeah I don't think
high level stuff happening behind the
scenes that's so nice how we accommodate
the yeah our special Sam is always very
conscious conscientious special needs
thank can I or maybe special requests
not special needs I was saying I have
special needs yeah that's the proper
special needs yeah I am very I'm very
special he has special needs yeah his
special need was non get out of here
Zach non-carcass
yeah Dan is our special needs uh we
might be overing it doing it a little
bit yeah sorry about that don't see
you're going for though apologies about
that
one um flew a little close to the
done Ian how's it going back there with
the
calculating give him one more second
okay the CR the numbers are still being
crunched the computer is still working
on it hold on the computer's smoking
dude
yeah somebody quick put a fan on it the
computer's on fire oh [__] oh my God
throw some water on it like you did
yesterday with some potatoes on it and
cook it you know I have a theory about
why my computer
exploded did it explode is that no the
the power supply Supply did okay so
sometimes the gardener and back oh he
Waters I don't know why he does he
Waters the ground yes I've seen that
concrete he Waters the concrete oh I
wonder I've heard that before and and
when I'm in the office there
I have the door I he liter he Waters the
the floor why is he doing that I frankly
don't really know just rcking up the
hours dude ask him to stop doing that I
don't like that he does it at all and
then people just step in it and it gets
dirty I guess to does that like just to
clean the the dust off of it guess clean
the floor but it doesn't make sense if
you just wet everything he doesn't
remove the dirt he just wets it and then
it dries he's very elusive too so I love
that he's elusive he's hard to get
at so but anyway the theory is that cuz
I leave the door cracked for alfredo
right and he's gone through there while
I'm in the office working and he's just
squirting water in the [__] office
and like I'm like dude chill okay yeah I
mean that defit my computer is on the
ground
close it's not super close right I could
draw kind of a chart I didn't think that
he could possibly hit it but my goodness
it doesn't take a whole lot of moisture
to I never thought about that but I
think you're on cuz I can't think of any
other reason why my [__]
exploded but anyway uh the the computer
is
buzzing uh it looks like we have the
results um there's a bonus one
here I have just all of them uh listed
here let's do start from the bottom the
least to the top here I can just I'll do
it like this so in last
place with a 6.9 that's right the sex
number was Zach oh no Zach I'm surprised
with your
potato the sweet potatoes tell tell me
about the process well I want to thank
Trader
Joe's stick of butter man hell yeah wait
why did you thank Trader Joe's wait cuz
those are Trader Joe's you just bought
them from Trader Joe's yeah
the [__] they're good man so you didn't
make it I mean I doctored them up I
added salt pepper but okay this [__]
sucks yeah that one was the hardest for
me to eat and you didn't even make it it
was the texture was nasty bro I tried it
wasn't nasty it's not my thing it's not
my thing Sam what are Zach what the hell
I tried man it's nice to know at least
the the sbot [__] got the lowest I'm
glad you tried though that would yeah
I'm yeah I gave you the old College try
it's just the baby food uh comparison I
couldn't I couldn't get past it the
college drop out maybe I shouldn't have
said that before we ate it yeah you
[__] me D sorry all right so Zach uh
congratulations shout out to Joe's you
know yeah and how did you buy this how
did it come uh it comes frozen and
they're like whole whole potatoes um and
they get when you heat them up they get
soft um and I just can you find me a
picture of the product I want to see
what exactly we're working with here
sure Trader Joe's frozen yeah sweet
potatoes let's
see
um I just want to get all the Intel that
we
can um to give it the
best here tell me oh this has got to be
it this has got to be it yeah is this it
Zach yeah that's it oh man that shit's
vile bro
probably I'd probably like it honestly
it looks
kind I gave an honest rating 7. look at
this [__] they're like yo look how good
these ones look and then this is
actually you get this
[__] okay shout out Joe's all right
coming in
third uh so I guess it it's a little
complicated I I forgot that love
actually had two entries it did yes
there were five total is it this last
one is another one
one
uh just that one was just a bonus yeah
Mo but there were five entries love love
doubled up he brought in two different
styles and so how should we do it was
did one of them get a significantly
different one is the winner but didn't
we eat four D so I'm confused hm didn't
we ate four things instead cuz you're
saying we ate five things we ate five
things we did we sure did oh okay well
you just spoiled the winner Dan w no
it's too late we only did oh the button
it's too late now it's probably too late
so let's just um well should we should
we say both of these entries give them
the highest and then we'll do the
honorable mention afterwards so let's
just do here why don't I just run
through them real quick so the next one
is Sam's with an 8.1 that was the duck
fat one which one is
that uh I believe that that was the one
that was you were saying was kind of
like a potato locky on we need we need
images yeah well
I don't have images okay so it was um is
it I guess it's this one with yeah the
one that looks exactly like that um the
ones I made that you tasted before were
fried in duck fat and those were fried
in Bacon Fat so slightly different so
Sam tell me about your process here um I
see you did the crunch the smash
technique yeah so I uh parboiled the
potatoes and then I smashed them and
then I fried them in duck fat and
they're basted with uh Teragon butter oh
that was the the special flavor
teron and I mean what is
Teragon Teragon it's some kind of it's a
herb it's a
her Teragon sounds like some cool
[__] Tech [__] yeah Sam um how was it
transferring from a fried or baked State
and then reheating it do you think that
worked against you or do you think you
worked that in okay um I think it was
all right I was going to air fry them
and uh our air fryer broke when I
plugged it in oh no no yeah that's what
I was trying to I had to heat I had to
heat everything up a different way oh
that's a
shame okay well Sam thank you uh for the
yeah everything was still tasting really
good and then Dan's special preparation
you just cooked it in like canola oil or
what yeah what was the difference I
clean the pan in between and I just
fried those as well mhm I mean what you
no but the actual original dish not the
reheating oh with oh with a duck I just
used butter use butter okay there you go
butter no animals died in the Mi butter
so all right so next up is love one of
Love's dish with an 8.16 so barely
edging out Sam and that was the chips
the ones that were
fun that was I Lov the chips than you
those may have been my favorite besides
you know not including myself of course
the ones that had like a little bit of
softness inside was so good that to me
is a perfect potato that's what I'm
saying it's the ratio of the crispy and
the inside soft it's like and then you
want I feel like you want as much
surface area as possible to get the
seasoning in there and get the
crunchiness those were great yeah the
sheepies they're fun because is so easy
you just [__] take out little uh
shees [__] juice boom boom boom boom
boom slap them the slap everything in a
bowl toss that around with some herbs
boom done and then did you bake it or
fry it U I had it in oven yeah tell me
about the temperature and the uh time uh
370 for a long time I don't I don't
calculate oh we're ring and then do you
crowd them or do you space them out like
one each craw that [__] slight overlap
um I have a little bit of I think we
crashed I think it we're effing we're up
we're effing we're up uh I think it's
that thing that happens where the app
all crashes for people we we're not
actually down everybody's things
simultaneously Shout Out YouTube that
shit's still been happening like I see a
views swinging by like 10,000 regular
yeah it's crazy psychotic good YouTube
you're doing great you're doing great
we're all rooting for you but I'm
surprised Sam I thought I had a little
bit of a s in my sleeve or whatever I
also used the Teragon herb yeah ter
yours were really good yours were great
I tried yours thank you I haven't tried
yours yet
but my dad always used Teragon for a lot
of things when I was younger so I've
just grown to like it and I figured I'll
I'll do some potatoes I've never heard
of Teragon I don't I've never cooked
with Teragon is the my favorite herb so
here is Teragon this is this looks
beautiful looks I think I know what it
is aromatic the thing is I type this one
first Teragon phonetically and there's
some kind of like a a swasti could came
up but not that right no no definitely
don't jeez yeah unassociated with the
herb that we all love now
what okay yeah I love those those are
really good I might do that I think
that's a good recipe too and you I use
uh what's it called the rrap seed oil
rap seed oil no I swear to God that's
what it's called I say that in in
Swedish is wrap seed it's literally
[__] kidding it's pronounced rap I
think we should adapt the Swedish way of
yeah
just being real understand being real I
saying that I think rape seed oil is
canola oil yeah canola oil for the
potatoes and the same thing yeah and
then also I made um I put the oh garlic
Teragon and garlic in oil and I just let
that sh Brew for a second
and then I poured that over the potatoes
before I put them in yummy so you did
canola canola for the
potatoes in majority but I also made um
Teragon and garlic oil that I let sit
for a while to kind of juice it up just
so people don't think I'm being silly
rape seed that's how it's you know what
I mean rape
seed it's just the oil what's what
possibly be wrong about me playing this
just you it's literally a household oil
literally everybody canol you know what
Zach can you hold that or no rap I would
prefer
not rape seed okay it's just an oil [__]
explain that to the algorithm Ethan they
figure it out they know what I'm doing
uh they know what they know the
[Music]
oil you know I was listening to your
Thanksgiving
drama explanation yeah the drama and I
think you're right that it was the
aluminum thing [__] pan because when
he made it the night before it was
really good I got gas lit into using
that
yeah I don't want to call anyone out but
I got some bad advice I was like are you
there I was a few people I was like are
you sure yeah they're like no it's the
same I was like okay trusting I'm
deferring to uh to life experience on
this trusting others 5%
more yeah thank you though for backing
me up on the all right by the way real
quick I boiled the potato before that's
the trick oh you did The Medallion one
Bo yeah both of my potatoes I boil them
wait wait so when do you cheese grade it
yeah uh after I boil it so you it still
chees grad cuz I don't boil it too long
it's just a soft just soften Ed soften
up a little bit when you cut it you'll
see the hard the middle is still hard
that's also why the outside gets crispy
and the middle is kind of un okay love
okay [__] the dude knows his way around
a
gr that's great I can to make those that
that I love very good okay thank
you Dan oh no Ian uh are you saying next
up yeah next up please all right next up
was
Ian with where did it go there it is
with a score of
8.4 that's pretty good so yours were
obviously the mhed potatoes at the
beginning that's so nice I didn't expect
um I didn't expect to I was worried this
morning when I was cooking them because
like you know how I'm I'm tweaking
everything but it came out really nice
I'm glad you guys liked it
yeah the next
one my technique on those is basically
to
something I focused on today which I
think actually worked out well is I
boiled usually I just spoil the [__] out
of them okay and it makes it really
creamy what I did today is I kept a
close watch and just boiled it up to the
exact moment where it was like Fork soft
and no longer cuz it starts to like
disintegrate yeah and so from there it
was a lot harder to mash but in the end
it had more of a it had more texture the
texture which I think yeah is good but
yeah I mean what's in it is really
simple um cuz I like all the herbs and
[__] but when it comes to this I just
keep it real simple just salt pepper
cream cheese and butter mhm that's it
but like AB said it tastes light and not
unhealthy Som it's not those that [__]
is crazy dude maybe because it was a it
wasn't completely fresh I feel like if
it's fresh it would feel it would taste
a lot
better yes it it does tastes better when
it's like right off the stove but I
think everybody did a good Jobe um
reheating everything it still tasted
fresh yeah I'm not going to make excuses
I think it reheated well yeah yeah yeah
it was fine
um you know somebody said everyone's
lying to you Ethan wait about about what
I guess I don't know I thought it would
be funny to read but apparently it's
just
confusing was it worth all the
lie I told the truth oh so you're imp
playing the other's L Kidd I'm playing
damn I'm not going to forget what you
did to me dude that [__] 10 damn that
was that was cold yeah you know for
everything
damn hit Ste it hit steep it hit me too
even just sitting next to you I got hit
I felt it really deep you know you broke
my heart listen I was raised on potatoes
I got I got some high standards
it's not that you didn't like it AB it's
the it's the that I didn't like the
delivery bro you hit me with the 10 and
then you swap it out it away I mean I
mean why would you do that I don't know
it's just you know man just a prank it's
painful
dude I'm going to be thinking about that
tonight that moment when I saw that
seven
revealed you broke my heart
I was like God
damn at that moment my heart crushed
into a million different pieces
dude you know somebody says we're all
going to act like Ethan didn't sabotage
that air
fryer I was thinking that oh yeah well
you know I got to do I do whatever it
takes to
win but ultimately I didn't win because
Love's steak fries yes so love did two
submissions I didn't I didn't even I
didn't even know you brought two
different versions and the steak prize
blew everybody's socks off how is that's
crazy that is crazy I'm kind of
surprised just because like for me
personally I thought your other Potato
dish was way better I love that one you
like the the chips more yeah I mean
universal Acclaim though by the judges
yeah the only reason it missed the
perfect score is cuz I knocked it down a
few points or maybe somebody else did
too and I knocked it down for the
consistency issue and so it's possible
that you just got two mediocre ones you
know what I mean can I ask they didn't
hit quite as hard as the ones that we
got is it possible and uh that my going
first could have resulted in a lower
score um yes it's hard to score the
first one it is hard to score the first
one you don't have Bine I'm happy you
know I'm happy with because you don't
know where to go from there right
although I'll say I gave you an 8.5 I
believe in that first round and thinking
back I I don't know if that's inaccurate
I think an 8.5 yeah I was happy with
that I thought that was nice so okay you
the second time you my eybrows but I
would have gone higher if it wasn't the
first to be honest really yeah yeah in
all honesty I would too it's like the
mashed potatoes you know and love but
with like a little twist a secret
ingredient oh thank you yeah well the in
truth I was never going to get a perfect
score so Love's Supremacy is
unchallenged love Supremacy so tell me
about these legendary steak fries love
rated Perfect by H3 podcast I think it's
the boil before honestly cuz when you
boil it it becomes a little bit gritty
almost it has ridges it's not flat and I
think those gdes kind of catch some oil
catches seasoning a little bit I don't
know are you secretly a Master Chef I I
I've been hinting to I I'm not a Master
Chef like s just hearing you talk about
the ridges and the half boil he's
cheesing I cook what I like that's
pretty much it I don't I'm not like a
Master Chef for anything I don't know
yeah no but very good it's just Vibes
you know just Vibes so how do you cut
the potato into the fries I cut I cut it
half and then I flat laid flat and I cut
like that so they're small they're kind
of small mediumsized potatoes no these
were actually probably big potatoes I'd
say I kind of it's just a Vibe it's a
quarter okay yeah it's half and then
it's the halves are split in three like
that so you get the wedges right I see I
see so it's thirds uh per half and if
it's a small potato you can cut it half
and then like that quarters depends and
then if you
um if you so then you put them in the
boiler and kind of do the same thing
where you just get it a little soft on
the outside uh I boil before I cut boil
before you cut that's the interesting
thing that I didn't expect I would never
expect that because I always assume like
you boil it until it's so soft right at
that point you can't cut it that's a
that's a nice technique to learn that
I'm picking up if you take your knife
and kind of um hit them a little bit you
you'll you'll feel that the outer layer
is soft but then when you get into the
core it should stick on the knife when
you pull it up still if it if it if it
goes off the knife when you lift it you
boil it too far it's too much boil and
then what do you do if you boiled it too
far then I make potatoes you just F say
[__] it you're done son yeah and
um are you surprised that you swept it
with a perfect score love does that
surprise you or is this what you
expected no I didn't expect that I was
just chilling vibing I figured I'd make
some potatoes but I don't think I would
win not over Sam cuz I know she's
actually that good Chef I think Sam's if
they were fresh out of the stove would
have would have done uh I would have
liked them a lot more mhm yeah I agree
fun to reheat definitely love yours were
really good though oh well thank you I
really liked them I tried both I thought
they were great that's very nice of you
that means a Sam a gracious gracious
competitor she truly is one of a kind so
talented I can't believe you were able
to reheat without the without the air
fryer I was sweating nous you get a on
reheating they were delish me and Dan
were in the lab trying to fix
it and love you had mentioned doing this
kind of spring potato right what
happened with that it's just too hard
and I got two big potatoes so when I cut
them and I I tried one and it just was
didn't work yeah it seems really
difficult to pull off too
annoying well I think we learned a lot
Zach was your intention always to just
buy something from Trader
Joel uh or did something happen and you
said [__]
it um yeah I was always to buy from
that's fine I'm not judging you I just
remember you were very excited to
participate I was excited about I was
excited to eat something that Zach
cooked yeah me too and that was taken
away from I'm a good cook but uh I don't
know what happened bro [__] pan was
too hot I don't know was too hot [__]
up [__] up not the right butter maybe
did you expect to get did you expect to
score well with those I mean I thought
they were Underdog man you thought maybe
they'd win they're they're heaters man
you had this fantasy that you would come
out and win and then be like it's from
Trader Joe's idiot they were my Rudy man
they were my [__] Johnny Football
Rudy man you know but they let me down
[__] [__] you Joe I tried I tried man I
tried I got a question for you Zach yes
sir did you make the cashier's day at
Trader Joe's at least I did yes I'm sure
you did you guys chat up big time oh
yeah what they ask you how's your day
going and then what' you say fine and
then did you did you follow up with
anything
um sometimes I like to divert the
conversation like just say fine you know
to try and end it see what they say next
you put it on them if they are you know
receptive and give it back then yeah
I'll be open to conversation but if I
just say the fine then uh and so what
happened in that moment was it open or
closed uh it was open they're like uh
what are you up to I'm like um buying
some poers and it's like
obviously they always ask questions
doesn't that annoy you they say what are
you up to and then you say I'm buying
potatoes it's like yeah well you're the
one that are selling me the potatoes I I
hate that I will say the more and more I
get older that I I do see the point of
like yeah this could get annoying like
if I'm not in the mood and just like I
don't know you're having an off day or
something like that then yeah I don't
want anyone to [__] talk to me that's
interesting cuz I thought it was the
opposite as you get older you just start
talking to anybody see I got the
Benjamin Button disorder words like I I
got the older part first and then you
know the more I get older the more
younger I get I guess right right
I don't go to Trader Yos cuz they talk
to me too much it's really annoying I
get Social Anxiety hold on and they're
like so any plans for the weekend it's
like yeah I'm not going to talk to you
about my weekend like sometimes they get
too specific and it creeps me out it's
like why are you asking me what I'm
going asking you about what you're
buying where are you going right now
it's like why are you asking me that
dude mind your own [__] business did
you drive here or do you live
nearby Jesus Christ let me alone they do
they do compliment you a lot which is
nice good for the self-esteem you know I
don't remember them complimenting me oh
I get complimented all the time what did
they say about you oh my God your nails
are awesome oh I love that shirt oh your
hair looks dope dude and you love and
you love that you take that to heart
[__] [__] juice me up
boy hold on that's interesting love so
you really do avoid Trader Joe's yeah
that's a shame because it's a great
store well I go there sometimes cuz it
is so good but no I really dread going
to Trader cuz that shit's scary I have
bad social anxiety too I'm right there
with you not to the point of like
avoiding going there but like I'll Stand
in the line and look at try to find the
person that's like looks like the least
talking 100% but that always could [__]
you over in the end I see their
interaction with others you can kind of
tell oh you gaug it yeah I watch I watch
how they're interacting with the current
customer I will say though those markets
and the parking lots are so [__] busy
man
the [__] cart traffic in there I I
will say I wanted to rip some people's
heads off just like just get the [__]
out of my way do it [__]
it should have done it yeah but you know
shout out Trader Jo got but After
experiencing it in New York this is
totally fine because in New York you
have to stand in a line that goes around
the building and still goes on all
inside the store until the cashier I
don't this is one of the things that we
hated the most that I don't think people
talk about enough is if you live in the
city the grocery shopping is abysmal it
is a [__] nightmare most of them are
just like little Bas or [__] up tiny
little stores and there's not a lot of
them and the shelves would Bey tooo
Joe's they're all getting mobbed because
there's not a lot and they're tiny and
there's a gajillion people that live
there so when we went to Trader Joe's in
Manhattan first of all we had to walk
because we didn't have an elevator right
it was a few blocks away but going up up
stairs in two blocks with [__] all
your groceries is a pain in the ass you
got to be selective like how much you
buy because you'll have to carry it back
but then you go in this Joe's and
there's a line going out of the window
out of the door and around the corner
yep and it goes up up a escalator Jesus
and out the door and around the corner
so you wait in line for like 20 minutes
and then you go out there and you have
to like compete with Shoppers because
there's cuz there's just not any good
groceries the [__] is just ravaged it it
it's so f up it's so f up it was really
shocking there there is a good Supply
with Trader Joe's La stock but I think
it's prerequisite if you're gonna
wherever Trader Joe's is you have to
have a [__] up parking lot because
every there's no parking lot at this
spot it there it's like every parking
lot is so small yeah yeah like what the
[__] actually I'm actually boycotting
Trader Joe's and have been for years
until they their act together with the
parking I park in a [__] Red Zone
like I I don't give a [__] I really
don't they all have terrible parking
interesting observation I don't think
I've ever been to a Trader Joe's all
over SoCal that doesn't have a tiny and
even in hcal that doesn't have a tiny
it's like the most popular grocery store
and there's 10 spots do you remember the
old the one by the old office that's by
design that was a nightmare the one by
the old office was small and it was a
big store it would cause a traffic jam
all the time because all the cars trying
to get into the parking lot they' be
backed up into the street bro I just
park in a [__] red dude I do not give
[__] do not I do not give a [__] they
don't instacart any of it too I don't
get why they don't do delivery or
anything cuz they they want to [__] with
you they want to talk to you they want
do they want to get to know you they
want to compliment you Cam they want to
know what you're doing this weekend man
I'll tell them I don't give a [__] the
food's good enough
but but so if somebody goes if a Trader
Joe's cashier goes what are you up to
this weekend would you honestly like
give him a rundown of your
weekend I might next time just to see
what happens cuz I feel like such a
dummy being like this man who I'll never
see again I'm going to open my [__]
heart right therapy one minute I'm not
going to see you anymore I'm going to
see my parents my mom isn't feeling good
though but I'm looking forward to you
know I got two young boys they love and
they're going to have fun it's like what
are we doing you could uh just say yeah
I got some rope and a tarp and you know
oh God that's actually pretty good [__]
with him dude that's actually kind of
funny social experiment what they say
then they'll never ask you
again you get put on the Joe's list yeah
traitorous Joe there needs to be like
you know how in Ubers you can do do not
talk to me they need like a button at
the front like yes I would guarantee you
like at least 70 people would be hitting
that well that that's what those [__]
Bells should be for you know those
[__] big ass like ringing Bells they
have there that's what it should be
don't talk to me [__] you know I I'm
seeing in the chat that this is actually
quite Universal
uh people chiming in that their Trader
Joe's from Place Florida Texas I'm
seeing all over the country has the
exact same
issu they think they're saving our rent
by like getting a smaller lot yeah I
guess there's one Trader Joe's that's
like the promised land in Massachusetts
it's right outside Patriot Stadium
Stadium massive [__] parking lot go
there it's the mecca for Trader
Joe's they do it everything's better in
Mass what do yeah dude outside
especially outside the Patriot Stadium
even though they [__] suck this year
but that's a they got flounder that kid
they [__] yeah they got flounder they
got tuna they got there's Twitter
accounts that tell you the lions at frer
Joe's in New York or tell you the lines
yeah tell you the lines like trffic
report yeah updates that is interesting
yeah man but like that's the thing you
get people talk to you all so
romantically about living in New York
City it's a rat hole dude it's a
[__] I mean it's there is nice and
it's fun in certain way a r hole but in
many other ways which New Yorkers don't
like to talk about they just want to say
how shitty La is and oo look at those
who wants to live there there's no
Seasons who would want to live in LA
there's no Seasons everybody's so fake
okay dude enjoy paying
$10,000 for a studio apartment and
carrying your weeks of groceries up
three flight of stairs I just had to
invest in a a [__] little trolley
thing cuz I was breaking my back out
like bringing that [__] up and I have an
elevator but like oh you trolley out
yeah dude oh I just got my brother I got
one too like the old ladies yeah like
the old ladies and everyone in my
building has them they all talk about
their dude mine is mine is badass I got
mine on Black Friday it's a whole wagon
it expands to a wagon for grocery
shopping groceries and packages yeah
wait you there's something in the water
all three of about you want to see it
I'll go grab it show the show a picture
yeah I want to see your trolley my
process I go to Target I get water old
lady and then I head over to Trader
Joe's what does that mean what's the old
lady trolley just to make sure everybody
knows what we're talking about grocery
oh you want okay Grocery and they
[__] they're awesome man I don't even
oh one of these little things that is so
funny is this what you're talking about
Jack mine mine is a a four-wheeler I got
an Offroad version why don't just a four
why not just use a shopping cart or like
a backpack it's to take it back home no
it's to take it back home like unloading
the car because I have to take it my
apartment is on you just put you don't
walk that far with the bags or I guess
you have to walk is your parking spot
far from your apartment it's pretty far
okay so that makes sense you just take
it up the elevator it's really easy when
I took public transport I use that all
the time too for like taking in the Bus
and Train so everybody's got the I could
fit two cases of water in there like
okay so yours yeah I got a [__] offro
let me see you have like big like Wheels
with fat um dude this shit's [__]
trick fat like a mud I took [__] Pimp
My Ride man you know something like this
Zach um this one has a cool Splash on
the front it's more of like a it shows
that it's waterproof maybe
it's there lots of
those what is happening yeah like the
one the one love has oh okay let's see
I'll tell you in New York gu right here
oh Big Boy look at those tires bro did
you just get that out of your car is
that why you have it okay oh it's an
actual wagon go offroading with that
it's a Radio Flyer man we have that for
the boys how many potatoes you put in
that thing dude that's a [__] human
grade wagon yeah it's full size but it
it it gets small it's goated man it it
makes your life so much pull that [__]
up look at that throw that right link
for that I and ab's got his trolley Zach
you have your trolley no it's um A's got
his trolley bust it out it's the same oh
it's the same one it's the same what you
wish okay about to he's talking probably
got lights in his or
something Tik Tok lights ambient
lighting bro that does look like the
same
one oh it's bigger is
flexing of course it is it's a b these
are better than our wagon Ean our wagon
is for human beings little ones wow a
really yeah we for the boys it's for
transporting bring them around in a
little wagon sometimes that is so sweet
it's fun sometimes damn that is a big
boy what the hell dude what are you I
mean case some water you can fit in
there oh wow you can fit a lot of water
in there look like four cases 450 lbs
whoa no shot it's rated for 450 lbs oh
my God let me sit in
that okay that around that thing's my
baby so but I you break for he's far
from he's far from 450 lb my friend
talking big
game H forget about potatoes let's rate
wagons
literally how do
I all right Ethan's inspecting
it taking off the Crocs right I'm get
I'm entering the
wagon wow
seems 30y certainly doesn't it looks
unfed and then let's get someone else
in ela yeah Ela you want to get in with
me we'd be like not even close
to ELA how much do you weigh right
now so 140 plus 180 I mean or way
under
exciting I mean really uh putting this
thing to the test you said 450 or 400
450 okay so we're we're good
man wow wow look at that no problem so
the brand my goodness uh they've really
made quite a product here analog
[Music]
Gatsby this is% off Black Friday it was
let me
[Music]
check up said he doesn't want to get
up under the hood
there go
on
[Music]
Zach I love that that was so good I love
when you do that you just you found the
perfect song and I want to just tell you
that I really love it thank you very
much I appreciate it here's a Twitter uh
account called J Trader Joe's line
alert this is specifically oh that's
good this one's in Brooklyn for the
Brooklyn I'll let you know how long the
line is not a bot just a quarantined
human okay Joe well have they been
keeping it up they still up to this his
last no his last week I guess he when
quarantine ended yeah but La his last
tweet was uh February 2nd 2021 he said
no line wow
okay if you needed to go to Trader Joe's
two years ago this is the account for
you 2025 20 people lined up before
opening well there needs to be is an
account Sundays at Trader Joe's in the
valley cuz Sundays at Trader Joe's
[__] that's if you want to get pissed
off
man there it is I hope someone from
Trader Joe's corporate is watching
because they might be they're losing
business with this whole greeting
nonsense just leave the people alone man
you know it's like you already got the
Hawaiian shirt and the puka shows you're
already festive enough we don't need to
talk also they got a do you know about
the um they hide different stuffed
animals at each location huh do you know
about that so one they like hide a
stuffed monkey and if uh you find it you
get a sticker and uh some other prize
what um so I don't I don't get the prize
but I will look for the uh stuffed
animal I never heard of that yeah yeah
they got like a pig at one it's good
time so I got that on Black Friday for
80 bucks what it's 1110 right now that's
such a good deal paid more for hours 450
what could you put in there you could
put all kinds of stuff in there you
could put go to Joe well you could put
concrete in it let's fill it with
concrete I realized now I ordered two of
them two different brands to try them
out that one's actually 350 oh wow the
other one's 450 the one I returned
because it was like oh that one's 350
yeah so we got kind of close to that
probably but it seemed fine yeah I Lena
sent a or I sent a picture in chat this
was dude we were right there we were at
like 40 I think we almost broke that
bit oh
[__] what it it held up yeah you should
be proud of that thing man a goodby
there's a picture in the Discord this is
me grabbing my packages on Black Friday
with
it where'd you put it it's in the
Discord oh I just oh here it is
okay here's a with this Black Friday
Clean Up what'd you get I most random
[__] we just moved so we needed a lot of
stuff oh yeah how's the new apartment we
love it awesome it's awesome having two
rooms It Feels So spacious good I'm
happy for you guys that's great you
that's
great there he is it's a lot of packages
buddy nice calves good definition it's
the uh it's the socks that gives the
illusion well whatever it is I like it
man thank you
yeah very good uh well I have a whole
bunch of [__] still to do all right so I
will probably head back home now for the
got to be with the boys yeah I'll try to
get home out of normal I really want to
end well we started late yeah so three
hours would be at what time when did we
start did we start at
two started at about two pretty much a
little later yeah so [__] maybe I won't
do three hours today
it's just the daylight this gets so dark
it's so depressing dude it really is
when I when we leave at like 5 6 we
usually leave around 6 right L it's like
the middle of the
night
mhm dark dark
no all right nice to see you thank you
to everybody that cooked yeah everything
was great yeah
ciao byebye byee the reason that
we the reason that we were started later
today is cuz we were doing our
Christmas portraits or yeah Christmas
portraits we did they came out really
good really really good I think we're
all very excited about yeah that was
fun see how I'm feeling
tomorrow you'll see how you're feeling
tomorrow I'm feeling it you're feeling
it I'm feeling
it oh you do you guys have like
sensitive backs or kind of yeah I um
years
ago uh I would think around when I was
like 20 uh got into two pretty severe
rear ending uh car accidents I got rear
ended at red light twice within a year
dude yeah uh completely separate
incidents and after the second one
especially it really [__] in my back
and I did physical therapy for a couple
years and it was a whole thing um and
that actually mostly fixed it but till
today we reversed it all today when when
we do things like we did today I
definitely a little bit but you did
great so far so good I mean that's why
I'm saying I'll see how I feel tomorrow
two rear ends that's really it was wild
I have a one of my really good friends
was rear ended at a stop sign or stop
light or whatever and he his back has
been [__] up it's really yeah shitty
just so unlucky and bad and dumb who
what was wrong with these
people uh idiots I don't know uh the
first time I saw it coming um and that
one was actually maybe more severe
because it was a big like um like one of
those white work van kind of things oh
God yeah so it was like a really big car
and it I looked in my rearview mirror
and saw that he was still going really
fast it just stopped at a light I'm like
uh this guy look like he's slowing down
yeah and then that happened uh and
slammed me me into the car in front of
me and that car hit another and that car
hit another it was like a huge like
Domino they like pushed all the cars
together so that sounds like it was a
pretty strong impact yeah but then the
second one that one was like pretty much
fine but then the second one uh was the
one that really messed me up and that
one I didn't even see coming I was like
just stopped at a light and I was
looking down changing the radio or
something and just out of nowhere I got
slammed into was this in the station
wagon the photo you you've showed me
uh yeah uh one was in the station wagon
the Volvo shout out Sweden hell yeah
that probably saved you and the other
was in a uh what car did I had I had
some little piece of [__] most of my
cars are little pieces of [__] but um
it's like a Mercury or something I only
had that car for a couple months before
that happened bro I had or no I had a
not a Mercury I had a Saturn was that
the one Saturn Saturn is really similar
to a Mercury car I think they might have
even been the same company but so what
happened when you get rear ended did you
get out of the car and like see what the
[__] yeah I mean exchange they were
apologetic obviously and say I don't
know what happened actually I remember
the second guy like weirdly I forget
exactly what he said he said something
weird why'd you stop there yeah exactly
like something like that and I
immediately was like bro shut the [__]
up I was stopped like you like I'm
stopped at a red light what do you want
me to do stop there and and he he backed
down like immediately but I don't know
thaten to me when in school like at a
red light that happened to me too oh you
got rear ended at red light too by a kid
from my school what are y'all doing what
was his deal uh he was just uh in
carpool and distracted and he paid out
of pocket cuz he he already had strikes
on his license oh oh God yeah we got to
get rid of that dude's license we
literally I got out of the car and I was
like crying cuz I had never been in an
accident before and he clearly had been
through it before because he was just
like
heyy my God I was like shaking as I was
like giving him my license I was so
devastated but um I was totally fine I
just was like damn it I got in an
accident and um Dan was there any
lawsuits involved in that I know the
insurance company insurance just ended
up taking care of it they just do
whatever yeah they they play this game
where they just Sue each other non-stop
I think that did happen for a while but
I don't know I I got paid out and I got
a different car pretty quickly after
that did you get some kind of
compensation for the physical therapy
yeah that too that's good yeah they
always say go to a [__]
chiropractor they may have recommended
that at the time and I wouldn't have
even been aware I I I don't think I had
developed my disdain for chiropractors
at that point ELO went to a chiropractor
recently it's a new I think people are
just starting to become aware people
take chiropractor seriously for a long
time yep still
[Music]
do damn I'm sorry your back
hurts no I'm I'm saying it's not
actually that bad right now I I know I'm
doing this but I don't know it's just
cuz we're talking about it well you guys
don't know what we're referring to we
did a photo shoot and it was very
physically intensive we did some
cheerleader [__] B I don't want to uh
spoil it but it was very physically
intensive Dan was on the ceiling it you
know was the whole thing the trapes yeah
anyway let's see so we got all kinds of
fun stuff to do
here
um oh [__] Zach okay from now you got to
do the vocal sound bites okay we wanted
to do that two hours into the episode
this is what happened last time we got
to do it at the beginning okay so then
we'll do it on Friday not GNA be here
Friday I guess we'll do it on Monday I
don't think we're going to do can't let
weasel out of it but we got to put it at
the top of the dock I don't think we're
going to do a whole episode though I'll
do it how about Monday oh Monday I will
start the show singing or some [__] all
right boom
Monday V
pen it in it's a date excited it's a
date uh
okay um lots of hubbub on the
subreddit hubbub because we did the see
you next Tuesday yesterday which was
very fun by the way thanks everyone who
watched we did a computer repair
stream for
members uh it was very fun we did it end
up being very straightforward and pretty
quick and spoiler Dan fixed it so thank
you to
Dan uh did you plug it in and turn it on
when you got home no I haven't plugged
in yet oh God watch it's going I will I
will tonight people are saying rip
leftovers and uh so here here's the clip
that's got everybody uh
buzzing here it
is people are saying rip leftovers um
yeah yeah probably just to be honest we
could just call call it leftovers a
that's so
good I wouldn't that be [__] up if I
was like leftovers is coming back that
is [__] up don't do that we were
talking about the idea of making a
cooking show right so that was the joke
there that was
uh which did you get did you hear any uh
feedback on the oven situ oven would
have been real nice today just saying I
mean I got I think the reaction was
somewhat mixed I saw some people people
saying they think it would be boring
really I a up but even if we don't make
a show dedicated to it I enough it would
be good but yeah I could like that idea
for segments and all that kind I got I
got the name man I got the name you know
I'm a name guy you are okay yeah cooking
with the clients
2ks very good 3ks
cooking no it' be too no three 3ks with
a with a cross burning in the back
okay force in that joke there we got
karaoke with the Klein cooking cooking
with the with the Kleins cool times KKK
Baby Cooking crafts with the Kleins
cooking crafts with the Kleins there you
go uh yeah
stupid hold on here we've never done
that before right we
never so I guess
people I
uh yeah I don't know probably probably I
just probably yeah it is probably over
just to I guess you know put it out
there people want to know and again I
said this on the members but I want to
emphasize that it me and Hassan are
still friends and this is nothing to do
with Hanan anything he's done
okay it's just that I'm deciding for
myself to uh not not do that show
anymore I mean you know what I mean I
know there's a lot of people upset that
like the show and I'm glad frankly I'm
hap I'm I'm I'm sorry that it's that
it's probably ending but I
do I'm grateful that everyone that
watched and enjoyed it it was it's nice
to see that people care care about it
and are you know but at the end of the
day I feel that you
know I need to be I need to look after
myself at a certain point and spend the
time my time doing something
that not spend my time doing something
that is going to you know be a net
negative for me you know it's just it's
it's my
life you know to a certain point it's
not it wasn't it stopped becoming a show
to an extent or at least just you know
the very end of it and you know it's my
life so I have to protect the sanctity
of that and uh that's that's why I'm
probably going to not do it
anymore any
questions I hear
typing we just all talking [__] back
here thanks that makes me feel good um
I'm Fielding questions uh if anyone has
AB speaking of which man we found the
culprit
I got I what is this meant to be is he
taking off with all the radiators what
is happening here cam I don't know we're
talking about car accidents it's funny I
could go through anything with that bad
boy I'm dry today I'm sorry some days it
no it's good Cameron it's good it's good
cam you're great you guys are great but
no it's good there was no one A to B
line of logic it was just car accidents
and that that's funny it's still funny
yeah I like he's Offroad maybe he caused
it what did he do there that's what I'm
thinking is that he caused that m
it's awesome it's a good time people are
saying rip leftovers
um uh so uh yeah it sucks that we're
going to miss the 2024 election maybe
we'll come back for it I don't know I
don't want I don't want
to um set any expectations anywhere you
know what I mean I'm going to keep it
just uh open for
myself uh
but I have a question go ahead is
collabing with ass in the future off the
table cuz I really want to hang out with
K again sometime oh my me too no of
course it's not off the table and that's
a good question thank you no it's not
off the table at all you know what I
mean
it's still the same as it was it's just
uh got you the show's the shows is on I
have a question how do they say it in
Hollywood they say it's on a indefinite
Hiatus yeah that's
correct what what AB do we do we have to
take down his portrait in the hallway do
you want to no I'm kidding I love thisan
yeah I was going to say you can leave it
up but if it's totally kid if you want
to remove it AB if it makes you
uncomfortable or something let's get rid
of
it but I like it I like
it let's so let's see here uh Johnny
says I totally respect that you need to
protect yourself but know that there are
those of us who love you and ass will
miss leftovers greatly that's not I mean
that is
nice uh to hear I didn't even real
realiz that there was such a
little
um kind of following cuz I mean it's the
least popular show on the channel not by
a lot I mean the views were really good
for a political show I think uh compared
to other stuff I think it was yeah
consist got like 500k to 700k yeah or
even more than that I think at the end
it was getting like I think 700 BS which
is great I mean it's great but I I
didn't realize so many people cared so
much about it to be honest that
surprised me um but I'm
grateful you
know when we first decided to do a
political show I was really not into the
idea but honestly I'm really going to
miss it I really to love that
show I completely understand yeah God
sucks let's do some
chestnuts someone says do an election
season special leftovers I mean that's I
like that idea I'm not committing to it
just to be clear because I want
expectations right you could go ahead
with it Zach keep it keep it
running but that does I do like that
idea it does sound fun you
know Carly says proud of you for making
a difficult choice for mental health
thank you Carly appreciate
that thank you so
much
[Music]
we were doing the photo shoot earlier uh
they were playing Christmas music and
they were playing the real version of
this and that that song is just ruined
for me now even if it's not a Nook dude
the original version
[Laughter]
sucks I'm [__] living for a Nook I
did it all for the
Ani love
him
wow what a
talent some people are asking is a new
Thursday show I'm I'm currently
unsure it's something that I'll be you
know floating around in my head until
something Co leses
probably um but for now I don't have any
immediate plans but I I'm you know my
head is always uh kind of thinking so
we'll see you and Jay
shett me me and J oh enlightened
monks what would be a good name for me
and J shed podcast Frenemies friend
overs um friend over friendenemies would
be kind of dope friend
overs can you keep it's a very one-sided
friend of me relationship between the
two of
you the beautiful and the
[Music]
brown that's that has kind of like a
negative implication the eyes the eyes I
know you were talking about the eyes but
you could cam you could do a really cool
one of like his beautiful eyes and then
my brown eyes
underneath the beautiful and the brown
right notown eyes brown eyes the
beautiful and the brown eyes threw me
off for a all
right what you me no yeah so maybe one
that's less uh ambiguous but yeah um
let's see um you and J shett I mean
what's like there's Frenemies is like a
you know a term for kind of like an
ambiguous relationship like
situationship when it's like a uh people
sort of pseudo dating or whatever what
what's like the word for that when it's
like one guy hates the other and the
other one doesn't really even think
about him I think that's just called an
obsession stalking obsessed with J you
could call it like The Odd Couple or
something like that the odd C all right
I'll I'll I'll message him right now he
looked I know he looked at the last one
I sent he didn't respond but he looked
at it you really going to ask him he
wants to co-host a podcast no no oh
someone said the J shett Show featuring
Ethan Klein oh that'd be perfect the
shed show somebody suggested the shed
show but the shed shed the shed shed
shet shed that's where the quartering
shet shed has all of his sexual tributes
to J shet the shet shed
anime
show what if me and
me and uh beautiful blue eyes did a
podcast where we talked about
anime I'm you know cooking with the
clients karaoke with the clein ketamine
with the clients could be good oh that'd
be a lot for every week but I don't hate
it just enter the khole with
us in the khole inclin
there was some conspiratorial takes that
this was all applauded on by Dan and I
think it was Ian who have been
passionate about launching the
Scooby-Doo Mountain Dew themed podcast
is there any validity though I didn't
want to bring it up but I mean we have
about 400 episodes
planned that really got legs that
concept do they do even a lot to cover
they've been talking about this show
since I started working
here okay may maybe that's a good maybe
that would be nice you know I'm sure
there just I'm sure people will be
tuning in for uh I don't know why you're
such a hater dude you're such a hater of
the do the do you guys want to do a
pilot you guys want to do a
pilot I I'm I'm willing to give it a
shot really I mean I'm I'm not going to
sign you because you shot this idea down
countless times in the past listen like
weekly basis we pitch this listen in my
opinion it's not a good idea for a show
that being said I might be I'm willing
to say I might be wrong and that I
appreciate your guys's passion in
bringing this idea forward and I want to
um enable you guys uhhuh and so I'm
happy to do a uh a pilot episode and
feel it out from there and if people
like it then yeah we can do the 300
episode
order I'm gonna I'm going to need at
least a 12 episode order for to make
sense up
front 10 the original Seinfeld season
had
six there's just too much to cover in
six I need 10 all right 10 I got can I
can I uh pitch you a podcast video is it
wine with the Klein no no no karaoke
with
the no it's called gossip all right and
we just rate go Gosling
movies that's a that's a fun twist yeah
interesting every week we just do a
different
pilot every
Thursday that won't get exhausting
making a new show every
week trying out one of our ideas each
could be funny though I mean I do like
the idea is making mebe like a
miniseries I don't think it's like a
Perman idea but I think it's a fun idea
AB I mean gos show I I think that has
some legs I mean how how many movies
does he have let's see not I'm not
trying to disparage the gos here God God
no gos know how many movies does Ryan I
think the roster might be stacked on
Gosling at least they say it's not an
exact number but they say we don't know
they say at least 71 so 71 yeah he's a
busy wow over a year of oh that's so
much juice that's a prolific a weekly
Ryan Gosling film review um series I
mean he's if you go all the way back to
the notebook that was 2004 that was that
was two 20 years ago and that's at least
at least a three-part series too for the
notebook yeah the notebook
more than a single podcast there's way
too much out so at the very least we
have 70 episodes which is over a year
minimum I can give you a 100 page
dissertation on
Drive okay that sounds interesting right
that would probably be
like I want to say like a year-long
project the drive is this embarrassing
to admit I don't know if it is or isn't
I've never seen the notebook I don't
know if that's like no it's fine you're
not miss I don't know if it's like
essential watching or anything watch the
podcast it's pretty
great it's not it's good it's a it's a
good when people say I people say this
it's a chick flick uh I
mean on a as far as being like a ro
romance sure because I because I like
romance movies if you like romance
movies it's a pretty good one I like Ro
romcoms do you like to be moved to
tears I will I allow myself to be moved
you should indulge in the notebook one
day when you're feeling vulnerable and
like you're ready to cry cuz it every
time I forget how sad it is every time
is there no happy ending to it it's just
pure sadness it's no it's it's it's
beautiful I'm not tell you anything it's
like life Ethan where are my shoes you I
didn't want to say it but you left your
shoes over here okay all right there
they
are um oh God Ryan Gosling is 43 by the
way what an old [__] idiot looks the
same as he did in The Notebook dude it's
weird I thought he was like 30s to be
honest 38 maybe I guess
38 but no he's old as [__] cring [__]
dude
cringe all right let's see what else we
got in the document here um fidus gets
beat up by a
monk oh well hold on there was one more
thing I wanted to say about the C next
or the leftovers thing uh keemstar got
in on
it keemstar he had some expert
commentary on it he just wants that
position does he hate does he hate Assan
more than me what's going on here or
maybe maybe Hassan hating is more right
now it's kind of a hot thing more in
Vogue yeah I don't think if he's if he
tweets about me people be like dude get
over it bro he said it all right right
so this is his new yeah so here he says
[__] over the last three days was
kicked off his podcast is he talking
about ours yeah that's not what happened
that's not what
happened bro you got to leave it's
keemstar bro you got to leave I'm
replacing
you got exposed for spreading fake news
and getting mainstream news stories
completely wrong H
keemstar saying that he's surely surely
there must be something to that yeah
yeah uh lost a debate he begged for
against drama YouTub
okay I don't even know what that's in me
neither defended Pokey oh that's the
worst crime oh that there you go that's
the slam dunk at the end I think he
wrote this about me and then he's like
uh let's change it to
S I don't think people are into the
Ethan hay right
now um okay well there you go keemstar
you got your Tweet out of it uh
congratulations the moment son saw Keem
chatting during his stream was one of
the funniest things I've seen live wait
what I gotta see that kassan was
chatting in his live that's
nuts I gotta know I need the lore on
that
one was kicked off his podcast what do
you think that I'm gonna hire you or
something Kem you being replaced with
keemstar keemstar is too keemstar's too
busy somebody said this is exact tweet
Keem wrote about Ethan after fren broke
up that's my point he could have subbed
me in easily for that
yeah so there it is shout out to the key
dreamy the cre the creamy key dreamy
award it goes to him and his uh
wonderful uh daughter who we love she's
a really terrific lady really mature for
her age I know that [__] I believe
that's his uh whoa whoa whoa what was
that girlfriend oh no whoa whoa whoa
what you yeah I think that's are you
referring to the the girl who's has the
braces with him no that's his daughter
no no that's his girlfriend no he's
actually dating that woman huh Yos also
she got her Braes off AB wait wait right
wasn't he at her graduation
beautiful I I I don't know what you're
referring to I thought I remember were
talking about different things I
remember a picture of him at her
graduation and I was like oh that's his
daughter maybe I'm misremembering
perhaps that didn't ever happen perhaps
I don't think that photo I can't tell
what level of trolling you're doing
right now I can't she's she's not his
daughter
bro holy [__] the Hannah
weo isn't she like
okay they each their own the words of
OJ uh there's lots of young girls with
Daddy and granddaddy issues out there
right you got that you you'd be
surprised surprised how many girls got
father issues and granddaddy issues
would be surprised how many of them
girls got granddaddy issues uh this one
was from New Hampshire it was one that I
liked so I got to you know say I did
like her and it wasn't a fleeing thing I
mean it lasted at least three days is
unhinged and uh this is
O we're in South Beach I mean not South
Beach we're on the beach there's a
street called Los olis Boulevard to me
the best Street in America clubs bars
and
good fresh new girls you know what I
mean Jesus I sure
don't I don't know man I'm M I just I'm
just at home with my wife I don't know
what you mean my my wife who by the way
is very much
alive not been stabbed I mean horrible
thing to say but no she has not been
stabbed you know what I mean yeah like
you know in contrast to OJ in contrast
to OJ whose ex-wife has been stabbed you
know what I
mean anyway thank you fidus gets beat up
by a monk let's check this out real fast
check him with our boy our favorite
cypron is that the right term he's from
Cyprus is he a cyprin I don't know what
the uh denym of Cyprus Cyprus
interesting we're nameing Pokemon C
cypriot oh that's ciot he sure is so yo
that's a cool one is this ree that right
hold on here yeah I think you're saying
it right cypriot
cypriot that's sick my favorite cypriot
it's me it's m this is from five months
ago so here he is with what's the video
called I trained with a sh Warriors for
7 Days Sweet let's see how he does 42
and he started practicing at 5 years old
so I've been here in this Temple and
he's uh our must here is a here's a clip
of me stealing the toilet
paper here is me stealing their
candlesticks that looked very
nice and he's train us for one week now
and is honestly I it's one of my favor
read p in the there it is not much to
see honestly but kind of funny looked
like he to be honest it looks like he
set him down gently honestly he want him
my favorite people in the he took it
easy on him definitely check his bag
though before he leaves it's all I'm
saying that's all I'm saying yeah Tana
uh friend of the show we've been talking
about Matt R he was on her
podcast and she got this really lovely
opportunity to talk to him here it
is check it out that's the thing I don't
really hate any I don't here's here's a
very humbling experience that I've sorry
I guess Epiphany that I've had recently
that because so many [__] people hate
me for really no reason and it really
made me realize that like people only
hate somebody they're jealous of and
I've been bro I this I don't you guys
probably know this I talk about this all
the time this is the dumbest I hate this
take so much people don't hate you
because they're jealous of you that's
like the most narcissistic freak thing
like how do you actually believe that
like sure sometimes sometimes not every
time not everyone that hates you is
jealous of you you know I'm not jealous
of OJ
Simpson
not
not I was going to say jealous of ab but
it wasn't funny cuz I do love
AB look killing Tan's punchline right
here
yeah it's just because of the rating
thing you did to me I'm sorry yeah it's
okay I love I'm jealous of you because
he's jealous I love
you so anyway here he continues you know
what I mean but it's so juvenile he goes
and again he goes I had this
humbling uh
Epiphany that actually all these people
that hate me they wish they were me they
want to be me oh that's so humbling bro
yeah I'm glad he actually framed it as
humbling he I'm GL I'm glad that you
humbled Yourself by imagining that
everybody wants to be you what a weirdo
super down toe guy I think he's just
really juvenile like you when you see
his Clips on Tik Tok he comes off like
sharp very sharp but in I think he's
quite young what's his age he's like 22
or something it's hard to tell because
of well 28 oh so never mind he's not
that juvenile so never
mind I mean 20 it's young it's young
yeah but it's not 22 young right I
mean 28 you're pretty much like grown up
by then I feel like 22 you still have a
few years you should know some people
hate him to hate him that's fine you
just got to live with that you know it's
like okay I'm not everyone's cup of tea
that's fine I'm they all wish they were
me you know what I
mean guilty of ha people and when I
really sat back and thought about it it
was because I was jealous of where that
person was in their life I thought like
maybe they got an opportunity that I
should have gotten this is this is one
of these cases that we see the world not
as it is but as we are Matt diagnosing
everybody with his you know jealousy yes
he gets mad at other comics and he's
jealous of their success because he
thinks he's Superior to them and he
should be there and he's thinking that
everybody has the exact same
uh impression of the world is him in
fact it's really just
a really a self-report I
[Music]
mean you know what I mean also his foot
is up that's that is an interesting
observation why is his foot up he's
making himself a little too comfortable
no I'm kidding this isn't even Beast
level bro what he's doing is fine I
wouldn't do it she's doing the same too
yeah but it's her studio right I
wouldn't put my foot there for the
record but I'm not going to call him out
for it
just to be just to be totally Frank with
everybody listening right now he sat
back and thought about it it was because
I was jealous of where that person was
in their life I thought like maybe they
got an opportunity that I should have
gotten that was a really really good
well-rounded answer I'm trying to wrap
my head around do you think people who
hate Osama Bin Laden are jealous of him
yeah that's the thing
I a perfect response I can't even handle
it there are people that are jealous to
some apparently by the Tik Tok trends
right I saw one of the top comments on
this clip said her line was funnier than
his whole standup special it was very
good I was actually really curious about
how he responded to that can we find the
time stamp I'm really curious to know
where the combo went from there but uh
we love Tana um she is a friend of the
show and we honor her on this day and we
say thank you for the laughs well done
so is this um would had that podcast
just dropped or did people uncover this
because of his recent controversy yeah
she he was on five months ago five
months ago oh so this is before people
really hated him I feel like this is
kind of inappropriate but yeah that's a
good point people didn't really hate him
until like a few weeks ago he's like
talking about intensified greatly right
I guess maybe maybe people did have a
problem this is a little I mean Netflix
is a joke the festival I would not go to
that Festival I would not recommend
anyone attend that
Festival even if Matt rif is
headlining it's just not safe probably
this
image that's Osama bin
[Laughter]
R yeah
uh uh actually speaking of of sama
that's a good segue into this next I've
been really wanting to talk about this
and
uh it's not exactly timely now but I did
want to wait yeah that's I I think I
actually took that section out because
we just it had been a few weeks we never
got to it yeah but I I find it so
fascinating that I do want to talk about
so it was you Dan yeah I said that the
other day oh I didn't remember yeah
Ethan asked I was looking through and I
was seeing all these stories in our dock
that had been in there for weeks and we
never got to it and I was like let's
just start cleaning some of this that's
fair yeah it's
fair um some young American ticktockers
are now realizing they're like oh we
should when we play the Tik toks we got
to put up the weow thing uh Ian we'll
get God I think yeah but they they're
going oh maybe Osama Bin Laden is
dope because Osama Bin Laden like a year
after the attack wrote a letter called
like a letter to America or something in
which he outlines why he did the
terrorist attacks um and that was
thoughtful of him to you know explain
his reasoning at least we know why you
know we like good communication we
appreciate it that being said I read the
whole letter which I hadn't read before
out of uh
curiosity and the
characterization of these people is
absolutely [__] unhinged I mean holy
smokes it's called letter to America I
mean look at
this and I am
ashamed here this morning I you put up
the
disavow
[Music]
there it is thank
you we disavow everything this [__]
loser says what an idiot how you going
to film yourself sing for Osama Bin
Laden just never ever do it and I know
some of you are going to jump to
conclusions here I don't want to spoil
the letter but like so I read the whole
thing so about I would say about 10% of
it criticism of America's support for
Israel the other 90 the other 70% I'll
say is him saying that he did the attack
because America isn't Sharia law and
that we're not all Muslims and that uh
gay people are too comfortable in our
society like crazy [__] they really
didn't read that part they just read
theed it you got all you really need is
the gist dude sometimes the cliff notes
is not enough right I never did it made
me uncomfortable even reading it and we
always back everything up in the dock
and I asked Zach to back it up for me
I'm like I don't even want to [__]
back that up with a Muslim name I'm good
you do that [__] better safe you
know stack all right no but it it's
truly like and my Epiphany actually
about this is kind of funny I remember
George Bush used to say they hate us for
our freedom and that's almost that's
been memed at this
point where because it's like so stupid
it sounds so dumb and I remember
listening to that and thinking like
that's what does that even mean like
that's just moronic reading the letter
it's actually true he hates us for our
freedom he's jealous of us he's he's so
jealous he literally says he hates
America because of the Rel uh fre uh
religious freedom uh uh self
determination he hates us for you know
being able to express our
our our uh attraction of people that un
that's not just CIS he it's straight up
he hates the freedoms that are in
Liberal societies it kind of blew my
mind I was like oh [__] George Bush was
was spitting a back well just on I mean
and then well the weapons of mass
destruction and the murdering like a
million people that was not
dope for the record not dope bad for and
actually for the record I'm totally
kidding I don't George Bush is a monster
and so is Dick Cheney so chill out I'm
just I just said shtick okay everybody
back up calmly and safely now you're
living thank you all right go ahead
dummy tell me how you love Osama Bin
Laden read letter to America which is
Osama Bin Laden's letter to America
explaining why he attacked
Americans and I am ashamed to say that I
not only have never read this letter but
I didn't even know this letter existed
it's wild and everyone should read it if
you haven't read it yet read it however
be
forewarned that this has left me very
disillusioned and I feel the same exact
way I felt when I was deconstructing
Christianity I feel I'm not going to
read uh a little bit confused like I
have entered into another timeline what
is this so I mean her again who are
you like do you hate gay people because
that was like one of the main thrusts do
you hate religious
freedom what the [__] are you doing do
you want to live in Sharia law like
there was it was like 10% about Israel I
just I'm Mind gobbed by this like yeah
he yeah he his criticism of Israel and
America was valid did you read the rest
of it dummy that wasn't even the reason
he did the [__]
attack we must stop the terror I call
upon All Nations to do everything they
can to stop these terrorist
Killers thank you now watch this
drive this classic that was the best
swaged out dude I've never seen that
video really oh that's iconic he got he
got slammed a lot for that that's part
of his presidency I mean looking back
though it's pretty iconic I mean
psychotic and
iconical confidence psic yeah I I sent a
little bit of a longer version at the
end I love how he has his feet up on the
little go-kart as he pulls away too like
that's our president let me watch that
that's our boy
Vibes with his dad see a church see a
church what Yik is he a comedian or
something see a church who is this guy
most powerful man in the world at the
time oh my God GE we were pretty young
Ethan and like and I'm not George Bush
monster um but George Bush monster he
was he was he was very goofy that was
part of why people liked him like it's
not really like something that people
talk about now but at least like he was
in the election and stuff like people
loved it it was a it was a very
minimized more refined version of
Trump's appeal of being kind of an idiot
but like in a way that people like and
he had that going on a
lot yeah he is pretty I mean yeah I know
what you mean he's he has an affable
yeah uh energy to him that being said he
did murder Joe Biden to be
honest funnier than Joe no in the way
that like Joe has like zingers a lot you
know mean Jo too old I feel like if Joe
we could scale the clock back like 10 or
15 Jo boy wake up he'd be crushing it to
that era to the early
2000s um oh thank you here I'm not going
to put the letter up because
it's probably not a good idea but I do I
do want to read you some excerpts from
his
letter um he it starts by saying you
know uh we love Allah we love why are so
he goes why are we opposing
you so first his first reason is because
you attack Us in Palestine so that was
the first thing he listed but by volume
you scroll down a few paragraphs and
then you get
into let's see these go and also let's
talk about like his conspiracy that Jews
um run all companies and World Banks
worldwide and that that whole thing was
a little problematic but uh I guess [__]
Israel is
enough
um looking for some Jewels
here uh I have the section that pretty
much is what you're talking about I mean
he he uh
about a third of the way in starts to
lay out what his demands are um the
things that he's calling us to do so the
first thing that they're calling to do
is to Islam everybody convert to Islam
he ends and he's like basically this is
what I want yall to do for me do this
for me right because we've entered these
negotiations in good faith right and
then the second so he says convert to
Islam convert to Islam is number one
number two second thing we do call you
to do is to stop your oppression okay uh
immorality and debauchery that is sped
amongst you what does he mean by that uh
people manners principle and Order
reject uh acts of fornication
homosexuality intoxicant gambling and
trading with interest that one feels
like a standout from the rest there he
goes you know why you know why we got
attacked because we trade with interest
bro that's our American god-given right
man did you read that part he hates us
cuz we do loon with
interest oh uh a lot of those things on
that list are some of my favorite things
though so literally fornication sure
what is he is that premarital I thought
that just meant having sex I in within
the context of what he's talking about
probably so we must stop premarital se
but I'm not married so I hope this girl
is a two together there she's like bro I
just realized that Sharia La would be
awesome and like I don't like I have a
student loan with with the debt and I
was like
yo yeah okay I mean maybe I can get
behind behind 0. Five there actually
trading with interest part there's more
right uh well let's see uh this is all
one subsection about why you shouldn't
be
gay uh I'm looking to see if there's a
third demand here blah blah blah he's
going into great detail about all this
all those things that I just listed here
so I'm still scrolling looking for we
got the high level notes on that yeah
I'm just trying to see if there's a new
uh Bin Laden
drop no like a third demand a third
demand seems like everything is
categorized into those two though by the
by the way the guy's a total hypocrite
when they when they got him finally in
his compound he had like porn and video
games and all this Western [__] the dude
was a total fraud living large I'm
seeing the third demand is releases The
Chronic yep oh [__] yep yeah the
original tapes uh a good one anyway
let's listen to her now that we know
that's what he wants he said America
this is what I want you to do he says
Sharia law become Muslim don't stop
being gay stop having sex before
marriage stop doing loans and gambling
and drinking right as you know all
Americans hate all those
things anti you know what I mean and
then the the third one was well he was
joking the actual third one I just found
is the you take an honest stance with
yourself and I doubt you will do so well
don't make assumptions like that why do
you have to throw that little aside in
there yeah come on bro that just is
prick is I thought we entered this in
good faith yeah this is just a
negotiation my guy uh what call you
thirdly to do is take an honest stance
with yourself and I doubt you will do so
to discover that you are a nation
without principles or manners all right
and that values and principles are
something you merely demand from others
not that which you yourself must adhere
to okay like I the criticism is
interesting Bad Manners standing alone
by itself but then when you realize his
his definition of righteous living and
like civilized living or whatever yeah
you can is
horrific absolutely be critical of our
own government and should be but um that
doesn't mean and frankly you have to
support AMA Bin Laden to frankly the
whole letter is not I read the whole
thing expecting to be more interesting
it's not even interesting it's frankly
pretty like surface level basic
terrorist [__] it's actually even dumber
than I thought um so anyway go ahead and
finish for
me and yeah so go read it so I just read
a letter to
America
and I will never look at life the same I
will never look
at this country the same I will never I
what please read it I'm assuming only
because he said that he doesn't like
what Israel's doing to Palestinians I
mean what else could they agree with and
it was such a small part of I mean yeah
the the whole like
beginning there's the Israel part
there's also he had a big issue with um
there being US troops in Saudi Arabia
right yeah yeah yeah yeah he mentioned
all kinds of like American imperialism
and so like the anti-imperialism like
angle in there yeah I mean I I agree
with those sections but like let me ask
saying I the world has changed I will
never
I will never see the world the same
after reading like you said what the
vast majority of this is which is just
kind
of literally dime a dozen criticism of
America right um the part that
apparently changed her life forever um
but I'd love to know Osama Bin Laden's
foreign policy of imperialism if would
he just be cool and chill or is you know
what I mean he probably wouldn't want to
invade surrounding uh countries and
expand his territory right he probably
super peaceful dude yeah yeah yeah like
how he fought for years in Afghanistan
right where he's from what happened
there I don't understand the reference
it's cuz he's not from
Afghanistan oh he's a [__] coloni
yeah no he's a he's a
Saudi oh he's from a very very prominent
Rich family in Saudi Arabia too dude
he's such a funny yeah no he's a total
he's like cosplaying as like a gorilla
well not cosplaying he he did fight as a
gorilla in Afghan fistan so he did a bit
of fighting yeah we love him for
that the the whole we wish him well made
me so nervous I spilled water all over
my laptop come on what's Happening what
um I do not condone this God Bless
America I'm out God Bless America man
you're leaving huh oh you got to dry
your your laptop's got to get out of
here um this actually frankly
I am not seeing these [__] these people
the same this is kind of mind-blowing
myself here it's like their hatred of
Israel is
actually
outweighing
their and it's also I don't know and
it's also
justan they're not that young Dan these
people well it's not about that it's
just about
like people who do this [__] on like Tik
Tok and stuff I I always have to like
wonder how much of it is is engagement
baiting yeah they're still putting their
face out there no it's stupid saying I
love or not I love but like vibing with
osam Osama yeah it's like the
extremities I feel like the way that gen
Z deals with them online it's like if
someone does something that humanizes
them or they get a new piece of data it
like shifts 100% And there's no Nuance
in opinion and that is what is really
really dangerous I think they're like yo
this guy said one thing I agree with
yeah I feel like that's a trend with a a
lot of things like interesting we get
one bit of info and then we're like
actually I realize I love this person
like when people go back and forth
online when they fight yep everything's
like Jud so this is osama's just em
embroiled in his first Tik Tok
Tesh yeah right yeah yeah yeah I think
people were like so eager to jump on
like commenting on this situation this
current sit uh recent situation and they
thought it was just going to be like uh
other conflicts and not really knowing
what the hell they're talking about and
just jumping in and not realizing yeah
how deep this goes and so they probably
posted stuff immediately got backlash
and they're like oh maybe I should look
into certain things maybe I should read
the rest of it right and then somehow
that led to maybe Osama had maybe he was
cooking God okay hold on AB that cannot
be a sound
bite huh you said osama's cooking
osama's I'm kidding should I button I
don't think so no no you're good okay
just a joke just a little humor
injection just a little humor if you are
also going through an existential crisis
in this very moment this girl's having
exist in the last 20 minutes my entire
viewpoint on the entire life I have
believed and I have
lived has changed I mean she crazy to
say after reading this letter she's
implying like pretty much exactly that
he was totally justified and she and his
reasons are all good and she's going to
change her entire life because of it
because of what she read in the last 20
minutes I guess she's going to go join
the Taliban good luck out there that's a
20 minutes my life has changed F yeah
the taliban's still out there you can go
join them right they're still they're
still out there doing shaking their
dicks doing yeah probably I think they
have like a Discord now or something I
Twitter maybe X sorry joke God Bless
America they're all on X now yeah there
I've
been please read that entire letter you
I wish the same for you I mean it's
possible that she did and agreed with
the bigoted stuff too who knows I don't
know who this person is or or more
likely is they scanned it like you said
or read the first couple the funny thing
about this and then rush to make a Tik
Tok they the the way that they frame it
is they remove all plausible deniability
they go I just spent 20 minutes of my
life reading this entire letter yeah
they're eliminating any chance to weasel
out of it later totally totally I don't
even think she read a small part of it I
just think they saw they saw the trend I
want film yourself saying something so
crazy it's not even it's not even that
different from Reading like hit mind
conf and being like Oh my he Hitler has
I don't I don't know what's in that book
I've never read it but maybe he's got
some good ideas about roads right and I
just totally changed my mind dude I
never thought about Hitler this way
before yeah I saw some really funny
jokes going around about this time was
like I just discovered this really great
book by this German um artist called my
struggle want to stop what they're doing
right now and go read it's literally two
pages go read a letter to America by the
way no it's not right that wait that
that kind of fix no it depends how it's
formatted it could be it's it could be
formatted I don't think there's any like
it's pretty long I mean it's a no it's
not it's it's not that long I mean like
I would say like pag maybe I guess let
me I'm going to drop it into a word
processor and see I mean i' it took me
about 20 minutes to read it probably
maybe less
15 um oh it's
3,800 words 3,800 that's a juicy little
essay to be honest it's a juicy little
essay to cook up in a cave
yeah um who's pading it but like he's
patting it this this girl I believe is
American I'm assuming based on her
accent but listen to what she says she
goes
ire letter I need everyone to stop what
they're doing right now and go read it's
literally two pages go read a letter to
America I I need everybody to stop what
they're doing and go read terrorist
propaganda RI for me real
fast who are you I cannot all right I'm
dropping into word Times New Roman oh
you 11o font seems pretty standard right
okay and the result seven
pages so maybe that's so she she she
probably I wonder if there was like a
definitely a lot more than two there's
no way wonder if there was a um like a
part that was just about Israel that
they thought was the whole thing
circulated it's possible it's possible
I'm giving them a lot of benefit of the
doubt on that a lot well like you said I
mean the previous woman really left her
no self no room maybe this was I read
every word of this essay and it spoke to
my soul well let's see what she
says and please come back here and just
let me know what you think because I
feel like I'm going through like an
existential crisis right now and a lot
of people are so I just need someone
else to be feeling this too I need I
kill to read the comments on
that so here's uh my boy I need you to
stop what you're doing and go read
letter to
America dude are you like a terrorist or
like recruiter like what are you doing
do you know what you're doing I mean
it's psycho it's it's
crazy like can we point this out as like
um
said the propaganda gobler Ethan why are
you
here dumbass what propaganda have I
gobbled say it I dare you you probably
love this essay whoever wrote that how
much do you love Osama Bin Laden freak
who said that I didn't see that I saw it
right here here let's look can we look
at their comment history no it's this
guy Trends t r i n z z z z what are you
talking about on
I don't know oh because on Twitch you
can show no you can't do that oh another
failure y because I I think that's so
cool when twitch people can pull up the
chat
history and get a look at these freaks
anyway go ahead dude uh send me to
Afghanistan stop what you're doing and
go read a letter to America it is
literally the craziest thing I've read
in a while and while I can't say that
I'm that surprised I am pretty
[Music]
shocked thank you that was good yeah
button that out
um resistance let me go back I don't
know how much got cut let's start it
over oh God damn it this morning I
read letter I mean can we call this
these people like leftist going too far
is that fair cuz I mean if you look at
like alt-right people that are I mean
they're basically Nazis but so what do
you call this is this leftist going too
far I me it's this is a handful of dumb
asses on Tik Tok I don't know I don't
know there there was a lot
of okay well so what I mean how many G
are out there right exactly I mean you
know people like to look at like you
know the alt riters
and I mean I do it [__] extrapolate a
lot of meaning from that like oh [__]
these are your
people but these people are [__] just
as crazy man are so I just need someone
else to be feeling this too I need you
to stop what you're doing and go read a
letter to America it is literally the
craziest thing I've read in a while and
while I can't say that I'm that someone
said yeah that button checked out you
don't even know what I said but that's
the point surprised I am pretty shocked
so go read it and tell me what you think
because I really also need to talk to
other people about this and actually
before you even read the letter I did
want to mention in reading the letter I
could only think of this tweet that I
saw the other day under settler
colonialism any kind of resistance is
branded as terrorist because the only
acceptable violence is Violence by the
occupier so this is [__] insane I
just read Osama Bin Laden's letter to
America which I will be going through
right here but it's actually so
mindfucking to me that terrorism has
been sold as this idea to the American
people and honestly just so many Western
inhabitants within certain Nation this
group of people this random group of
people just suddenly wakes up one day
and just [__] hates you just wants
you dead wants you gone and this is all
okay you know what I'll take it I mean
she said big for a I didn't push that
button though just for the record
I
mean hold on let's let her finish so far
so far this one has been a little bit
more reasonable to be honest I I
disagree I'm waiting to see where this
turns I don't think this is going to end
well I think it's fair like because I do
think that that is a fair point to make
I mean I I think I I think it probably
is good for people to read his letter
and to pay attention to the exact things
that they're saying and and should have
back then too because yeah that's that's
not healthy
for uh for anybody to just operate under
this assumption that they just they just
hate us just because because we cuz they
jealous you know what I mean that really
is well it's not a good way to when they
the thing was they hate us for our
freedoms bush used to say all the time
and you know I kind of was like oh [__]
that's kind of true but he doesn't impa
unpack that in any kind of meaningful
way and it sounds cartoonish yeah it and
it is cartoonish because I mean there
are there sure I mean go read it's a
historical document it's interesting but
these people are endorsing it they're
not [__] saying go educate yourself
about Osama Bin Laden they're literally
endorsing this [__] letter mhm it's
just again it's like the extremes of it
with they have a criticism of
America and then they find this Outlet
to to use it
but I think it's misguided let's hear
what she's saying though let's let her
finish believe that they're better than
like that is the root of terrorism it
doesn't make sense they just hate your
[__] Nation but reading this letter
it becomes apparent to me that the
actions of 9/11 and those acts committed
against the USA and its people were all
just the buildup of our government
failing other
nations okay again his request to
America was clearly outlined he says if
you don't want to get terrorized here's
what you must do convert to Islam under
Sharia law basically [__] kill gay
people and out and people that enjoy all
this [__] yeah and I I don't and I don't
know anything about that woman or it's
so I can't even I can't I can't even
honestly give them Deni uh a reasonable
deniability because like it's so [__]
wrong and crazy to even put yourself out
there even saying this like it's so like
clearly they didn't I don't think that
most of them I understood exactly what
they endorsing but it's so irresponsible
it's so
[__] dumb that like dude holy [__]
and again if you read the whole thing
it's not like Israel bad it's Jews are
bad it's Jewish people are bad Jewish
people in America are bad Jewish people
in Israel are bad it's like very [__]
anti-semitic too and not and I'm not
saying that like oh everything's it is
very clearly no he's explicit about it
yeah he does he's not shy about it what
what confuses me about these people and
maybe it is just ignorance and this is
why I uh hesitate when when you say do
you think you know these are just like
misguided leftists or whatever I or
leftists going too
far if you actually know the history
about Osama Bin Laden there's a lot to
criticize there but Osama Bin Laden uh
came to be as a function of our
government the CIA backing him and other
terrorist groups in Afghanistan fighting
the Soviet Union it was part of our
efforts to undermine the Soviet Union
you know the communist country
and so Osama Bin Laden has never been a
friend to leftist uh even if there is
that streak of
anti-imperialism and confl like just
taking that and running with it it's
like if you want to make the
anti-imperialism argument there are a
lot better people to be holding up than
Osama bin
L all of them good point there's lots of
anti-imperial American uh Scholars
Educators tons of them I mean it's a
Well TR
Topic at this point especially in
colleges and stuff that's a good point
there's about a kajillion other people
that have like way more based takes I
think it truly is just like a group of
kids realizing that Osama Bin Laden was
a real guy and they're just like oh he
had he had thoughts and he had he wasn't
a cartoon character evil he wasn't a
family guy who character that shows up
for a gag yeah shoot the son of a [__]
I'm going to pass the question off to
you guys what do you think what do you
think about
letter so true ab and then can we get
some like can we get likes for Osama
retweets for uh
Bush thank
you go on you're cooking you guys are
killing
it me when I got the news that we got
him in
2011 she stoked woohoo yeah she
celebrating 2023 reading his letter to
America knowing he was right wa
who whoa It's also just like like you
pointed out you know if we just for a
second cast decide you know whether osam
you know Osama had a point or not uh
putting this on the internet like why
are you doing that what do you stand
yeah you are you are [__] yourself
over literally life ruining don't do
that you do not want yourself on camera
saying Osama Bin Laden was right yeah
people people going to Google you at
some point and that is going to pop up
and it's going to be a problem wait is
this is this girl a YouTuber do I
recognize her or is it someone else um I
don't personally but let me let me see
who that is she cuz like there's a girl
that looks like her that makes YouTube
videos that I've seen I saw you know
what maybe cuz earlier in the chat I saw
somebody referring to uh to them by name
it was like Maya or Mia or something I
don't know if that's that's crazy cuz
she's like you know does somewhat
thoughtful funny uh cultural topical
videos I mean I found her clip to be the
least offensive of all of them to be
honest let me rewatch that then I want
to give her that was the one I was
saying is let's let's give her a fair
Shake here so this is [__] insane I
just read Osama Bin Laden's letter to
America which I will be going through
right here but oh we need her analysis
it's actually so mind [__] to me that
terrorism has been sold as this idea to
the American people and honestly just so
many Western inhabitants within certain
Nations that this group of people this
random group of people just suddenly
wakes up one day and just [__] hates
you just wants you dead wants you gone
and this is all because they believe
that they're better than like that is
the root of terrorism it doesn't make
sense they just hate your [__] Nation
but reading this letter it becomes
apparent to me that the actions of 911
and and those acts committed against the
whoa whoa whoa we need to disclaim her
Ian but we're determining if she's a
dumbass or not right now no we need the
disclaimer okay just in case I
guess got to keep it safe here yeah USA
and its people we're all just the
buildup of our government failing other
nations yeah I don't find what she said
there that objectionable the whole thing
about again about there's a second part
of her by the wayo Yeah and I don't I'm
only commenting on that clip I don't
want to's see I don't want to get
clipped myself let me think here she
says she's pointing out that a lot of
people have a very simplistic kind of
almost cartoonish evil idea about
terrorists that is kind of Divide from
culture look you can learn about the
historical facts of American imperialism
and and and how that like funding the
Taliban to fight Russia and all this
stuff there's nothing in his letter that
is supportive or interesting or
Illuminating about that like sending
that specifically sending people to the
letter to learn that is [__]
psychotic it is
psychotic right I mean I don't know I
know what you're saying but I think just
the act of sending people to read this
letter in a kind of way that's like a
even a little bit end dorsy of it is
psychotic and that's well it is and to
be fair you said that there's more to
that video and I don't let's watch it I
got it right here let's see
in majority of these situations and this
letter was insanely eye-opening I really
urge everybody to Google and read it
it's because I thought that I had quite
a lot of media literacy it is not
insanely eye openening it's not I mean
maybe if you're total
ignoramus I don't know it's not it's
just not it's literally just an
anti-semitic homophobic [__]
religious fundamentalist rant of a
dollar store
terrorist
but this takes it to a whole another
[__] level where I was just like holy
[__] like propaganda is genuinely so
deeply embedded into our [__] DNA Red
Alert to America I don't know I'm not a
fan I'm okay with you saying I'm I'm
okay with like oh maybe it's not as bad
as people being like yo that was awesome
he was based as [__] again the part that
I was trying to point to was just fair
enough by reading it it dispels sort of
the cartoonish image that in our mind
that we have of these people and that
doesn't mean that you should agree with
what he's saying
but under seeing what the actual
perspective is is and understanding that
I think is more productive than
dismissing them as they they hate us
because they ain't
us it's a pretty good way to put it
though I do like that as a foreign
policy as a they just hate us cuz they
Ain US America number one baby objective
I do find that
compelling okay you're probably waking
up you probably have a lot of questions
welcome to the club but we don't have a
lot of time to sit and talk about
everything because there's still so many
puzzle pieces that we just do not know
about go read someone said I think it
might be important to recognize that
using the term anti-Semitism when
referring to Arabs is also inflammatory
because Arabs and semantic people as
well I have to tell you I find the
semantical game people play with this
word absolutely MN numbingly dumb like I
understand that Arabs are technically
semetic people but we're talking about
the common usage of the word everybody
understands the the um the common usage
of anti-Semitism it means hatred of Jews
there's also words that mean hatred of
Arabs there's islamophobia there's uh uh
I I guess I don't know if there's a word
for not specifically Arab I guess people
kind of do a catch all of islamophobia
even though that's not true they're not
all well not all Arabs are yeah even mus
but but I'm just saying like
um it's it's so they go how can I be
anti-semitic if I'm Semitic myself it's
like no you hate Jews that's the
accusation I'm not I'm talking
hypothetically I'm not saying anyone
specifically is but there the claim is
that you hate Jews not that you hate all
semetic people this semantical game is
dumb as [__] it's stupid yeah yeah Ethan
hates Islam we get it thanks man why are
you here again when I went home uh last
month for the weekend people were asking
me about the com and oh if it does not
about you specifically but if it does
come out publicly you know you just you
know people try to say you're being
anti-semitic and they said argue it
because we're we're semetic but I'm like
dude that's so that's clearly not what
they're saying like we're not arguing
terms here that's that's not what people
are saying when they say that they're
feeling uh you know anti-semitic shit's
happening to them exactly it's like it's
like saying um you
know uh I had a brain fart and then
they're like well hold on did you really
expel gas from your brain I mean listen
words have common parling we we use them
we know what it means okay don't stop
being a [__] idiot sound dumb when
you say it I hate
you okay okay sorry got a little worked
up here you know what I mean I don't
have an outlet for this stuff right now
just so you know it is debate bro it
that's you know H always says debate
perverts that's a debate per pervert
tactic yeah yeah yeah yeah oh really how
can I be anti-semitic if I'm Semitic it
just means you hate Jewish people you
can hate Jewish people and be a sematic
person technically you're right and it's
just kind of a derailing tactic
essentially to just kind of like I mean
it's a stram take it into semantics
there's a lot of very similar words
debate Bros arguing semantics thank you
you guys understand me it's straight
debate per semantic diffusion is what
it's called ooh oh that's fun you could
bust out that that's a cool little term
to bust out although that's pretty
debate pervert too to be like it's
straight bro you're just doing semantic
diffusion right now well if they are I
think you're right though I think that
straight up debate pedophilia right yeah
I love how it's turned into like this
arms race of how
perverted this is straight uh debate
holocauster right
now anyway go on I love these people
they're great read a letter to America
like seriously go read it type a letter
to America in Google or whatever you use
then come right back I'll actually say
something it was kind of hard for me to
find the letter cuz I know there was
some hubbub about so the guardian had a
post where it was up for decades and
then they removed it when people started
reading it which I thought was in
utterly insane very very stupid decision
why did they do that newspaper man some
people were arguing the legitimacy of it
coming from him that's what I was saying
in term I was trying to find out why
they removed it as well but no I
understand it to be very yeah it's
reputable was up for decades and they
they literally took it down when this
Tik Tok [__] started we should host it
on Ryan kavar website which
I that's kind of f ah that could
backfire yeah do that um but I see that
backfire it's such a bizarre choice to
do that because why would they
uh all that does is a m like make it
seem uh oh it's banned it's like oh now
they don't want us to read it so now I
really got to read it we're scared of it
right and then also because it's not on
because now it's being like reposted
other places it's not on a reputable
website where it's existed for decades
so you know it's the real letter
like I don't even know maybe that one
girl did say it's only two pages maybe
that is what she was shown and it had
all of the really homophobic igot
language stripped from it which is nice
I think we should whitewash Osama right
but my point being is like that's why
it's dumb that the guardian removed it
because now who knows what people are
even really reading by a reputable news
source it's utterly insane like whoever
made that decision should sit in
disgrace and shame it was so dumb if it
did anything it just enabled these
people more to be like oh they they
don't want you to read it CU it's true
yeah it's so dumb dude very dumb I
[__] hate
you all right it down this is me without
the leftovers
right which isn't a great endorsement
frankly of ending the show but it is
what it is and it ain't what it
ain't because this makes a lot more
sense it explains so much and I
guarantee you it's going to blow your
one thing I can say about these people
is they're all Libs I feel that these
are all like protr Pro gay right left
leftist and they're conveniently like uh
just yeah which I mean ignoring the
attack at their very core of who they
are uh but okay whatever decide with a
CIA asset again it's just like bizarre
CIA asset what is that he was he was in
the 80s okay when he was fighting well
conspiracy theorists think he still was
when he attacked America but we don't
need to get into that orange Buster had
a really great point he says I'm not
antiemetic I'm anti-semantic
oh I'm hardcore anti- good that's so
good that's really
good and let's talk about it so go read
it Ethan do you hate them or are you
just jealous of them that's true it's so
true come
back it's a lot it's a lot it's really
not finding out we got him while I was
in service in 2011 you're a service
member
okay she's like we got him yay that was
awesome seeing his letter to America now
knowing he was right
oh
yo you put that online with your face on
it
lady he was right about what exactly go
on
explain I mean it's it's just it's
wild letter to America is something you
remember where you were when you found
out Osama Bin Laden had been shot by
with lethal kinetic Force I didn't find
that whole thing to be that compelling
the only frankly the only reason that I
remember is because the only sign of
anybody celebrating I saw was on Ventura
Boulevard there was a single dude waving
a giant American flag we got him
screaming we got him we got him and he
was just having the time of his life
just one guy maybe if you lost really
stuck out to me or lost service member
York or you were traumatized by it um
yeah maybe in New York there was a much
bigger deal I I don't know it's like all
right I mean we got him but yeah I just
remember looking out the window and
seeing this dude and he was just he was
loving life yeah it didn't really affect
my day that
much but I was like okay we got him we
got him we got him we got him we got him
guys finally uh this girl says letter to
America is something everyone needs to
read all it all makes sense now
especially if you're live during 911 go
on
oh oh my God she
says mood since reading osama's letter
to America I'm think rethinking things I
grew up learning I mean it's not that
bad but like again the context of the
letter is just not it girl it's just not
it like I I think these people they want
to be karian they want to be woke to the
sense of like I see things for how they
are and not what they say it is there's
a lot of this I think of people W people
who go like too woke too far to the left
or and maybe not that's not the right
but like maybe it's more like The Virtue
uh where they want to prove how virtuous
they are compared to other people and
they just really they did a whole like
they walked all the way around the globe
and ended back up like maybe engagement
B was the wrong term that I used earlier
but there it I know what you mean by
that it's part of like the [__]
insane social media addiction that
everybody has they want they want um
validation yeah or just to have I don't
know to just have a a spicy post or
whatever whatever you want to call it I
don't
know I do think people should read it I
mean it was interest I found it
interesting to read although more so
just in the context of everything I mean
I agree
not that interesting I think with with
with the mindset of just wanting to get
a better understanding of
who what of the mindset of somebody that
could do something so terrible like that
um I think is valuable yeah and it's
valuable to to understand it just for
the sake of it's
historical he got us for history and but
also for the future to just yeah I mean
again there there is some
Anti-Imperialist uh rhetoric weaved
throughout all of the the gay bashing
and stuff and you know
it I think it's important to know
why
uh why it happened and to not just
dismiss it as um they're evil they did
it because because they're evil and they
hate us I think especially the kids like
my age because we were babies when it
happened so I just grew up thinking like
oh Osama Bin Laden is the evil of like
against America but at the same time I
do feel that people take that too far
agree I like because like he is evil and
his ideas are like straight cultish
religious fundamentalist violent crazy
[__] right and I think now he was
enabled by America at a certain point
but this dude believes that [__] and you
know again it's yeah and I think that
that context is like I think that that
actually is important and a better way
of kind of approaching an
Anti-Imperialist mindset is like read
this see how [__] unhinged and
bigoted and and horrible this dude is
and understand that we backed this dude
yeah that's a good context for sure you
know we gave these guys a bunch of guns
a bunch of guns and then they turned
around and attacked us which is kind of
maybe we need to stop doing that it's
actually incredibly shortsighted because
he's like I hate everything about in
osama's worldview probably Russia and
America are identical to him
because they're not you know I don't
think he sees a big difference we're
just we're all Sinners and we all need
to be you know right converted you made
me defend this dude yeah I know man no
no don't do it don't do it no did preach
just defend Osama preach no don't for it
don't fall for it by the way I'm kidding
preach I know you didn't support when we
talk about burning the witch you know
the era where we used to burn the witch
that era never really stopped the type
of witch we was burnings changed mhm
yeah
interesting go on a you a
[__] okay all right all right all right
you you probably have to go right hold
on I'm almost stopped the video I'm
committed now all right so I said I read
Osama Bin Laden's letter to America the
way Palestine is freeing us from
falsehood letter to America the way this
letter is going viral right now is
giving me the way P the greatest sense
of relief if you're Muslim and you've
lived in the US since 911 you know more
truth than the typical citizen now it's
all coming to light because of
Palestine that's pretty unhinged you you
just read some been blonded to America
and knows the media is trying to bury it
that I mean yes exactly so dumb dumb
asses why did they do that what pathetic
losers like holy [__] such a bad call I
guess Panic they're like what do we do
they don't want to be blamed they're not
going to find it somewhere else dummy
yeah it's just and a less reputable
place again where they're not
necessarily reading the original letter
and it is what it is sure
is uh she's really okay so I mean that's
it I I wanted to talk about this because
it's just so
nuts but there it is looking forward to
next week well yeah I I do think that
there's this really underground German
painter who's really got interesting
ideas I struggle like him we all
struggle and that's why it's Universal
right God some of you people in chat are
such pathetic [__] losers like if you
okay I'm not going to get into
this I'm not going to get into it but
you know who I'm talking if you're out
there and you think I'm talking about
you I
am all right let's do eel pit do we have
time for eel
pit I mean you're the one that has to go
it's it's 510 oh [__] yeah [__] I had
eel pit at the end of the
dock next time I mean it's kind of an
evergreen story it's kind of it it is
what it is but you're the one that has
to go so I don't know hold on what's
this this is also what the [__] oh this
is oh God OS Osama if he was today could
be doing crazy Tik toks that's true is
he doing the NPC thing he would have
crazy lives he would have crazy lives
thank you for the gift have you ever
seen Osama bin lon's um new metal uh is
it his brother or his son I
forget oh his I think it's his brother I
think it's a brother he's like a cool
ass dude right well or no he or I don't
know depending on
how maybe I don't know who is he what
are you talking about I'm trying to find
the picture of him you know what I'm
talking about cam I feel like you would
know about this the new metal brother
Bin Laden
brother metal what's new metal I got to
find it because if I don't I just seem
insane I typed Osama Bin Laden's cool
relative cool he's been he's been exiled
from his family too we should this guy
oh it's this okay this guy yeah this guy
he's like metal like Zach would like him
his product product here here or what
the [__] yeah it's his son son dude look
at that check this guy out oh that guy
[__] hard dude dude AMA you couldn't
even get your own son on board with this
[__] seen him before homie [__] what's
his story that's a cool guy uh uh is
grown into a goth metal hybrid he loves
western movies and dude he looks like
every member of System of a Down
combined D surge man but he's like all
of them in one dude he looks dope he
looks nice he's a paint
America is his oh God no not another
painter paint bro go go back to picture
back lives in Germany and paints that
looks like he looks like Zappa too man
oh he does look like Zappa there true
that he painted the off the rails
background right there he actually no
it's been on set the whole time he says
America is his Muse he he says
Unforgiven he western movies well I can
I guess I can forgive him for that
Unforgiven that's a great movie
it's pretty so there you go that is kind
of Omar shout out that is nice should we
do it side by side with Hitler or no no
okay just crossing my teeth let's not
provoke anything I he is osama's son we
got to be a little just look at ex just
like okay I think one of one of a lot be
like okay he he has tons of kids he
[__] like crazy really yeah be like
are you cool he's like yeah I'm cool
I'll be like okay dope let's have him on
the show have you ever seen I talk to
that' be cool have you ever seen Osama
Bin Laden in Sweden no VI I have not
wait can we reach out to his son that
could be
interesting um I I don't know I mean
let's try if you want me yeah if you
want me to I'm done why not uh this is
like the lowest resolution this there he
is right here in like the 70s or
something ah he didn't get enough
attention that's what happened yeah
right he one of many a big big family
that's his whole Jesus Christ he GRE up
that's all his family I think he uh I
know he was educated somewhere in Europe
it may have been Sweden I feel like I
should know that so he may this may have
just been a visit I might be misre just
visiting guys this is a famous photo of
him apparently he went to a college with
Kim Jong-un as they enjoyed uh the
university system Kim Jong-un went to
college in America right no I think he
was in Europe got that switch yeah he
apparently he was like really good at
basetball he was a good student he had
like a really good time in the western
Society yeah and he he got pulled back
because of something right a war I think
like abruptly they're like his dad
died yeah you need to come be king I
don't know how he went from like a dude
who was like kicking it with the homies
playing basketball to this square-headed
[__] well he still [__] with B
basketball yeah yeah well that's why
yeah Dennis Rodman yeah I was going to
say Dennis Rodman dude I wonder if we
get Dennis Man Kim when he became king
he let that [__] he let it all go we
actually have a friend of the show who
knows Dennis if we uh oh that's right
yeah he's so but like if you try to talk
to him about Kim he treats him like with
the highest reverence he's like no he's
my homie I don't talk about
him we we don't talk about
that why are people spamming John
Cena they want the the one where he's
speaking Chinese oh John Cena I don't
think it has anything to do with that
wait why are you guys spamming John Cena
because I want to watch it
oh John Cena announcing Bin Laden's
death I want do want to see that have
you ever seen that one before I don't
remember recall it no this is the origin
of the uh uh well you'll see I I won't
spoil it and then after that send me the
one of him apologizing to the people
don't you have to go for real though no
we we're wrapping it up I'm having too
much fun here guys God I I'm keep going
down this uh wait a minute I don't think
we can actually watch the John Cena clip
it's going to get claimed because it's
from WWE and they're very strict about
it I'm not going to play it I'm just
opening it oh okay can we play the
audio it's up to you if you want to if
you want to risk it the audio is the
most important part I mean it might does
he come out to his theme song cuz that
might no I can just skip right to the
part where he does it here yeah do that
do that it's only 10
seconds we have caught and compromised
to a permanent end Osama
been
live this is americanism gone dumb as
hell compromised to a permanent end like
a [__] Stadium of WWE
fans uh and John Cena announcing to
everybody's Glee that we got him is
American Dum such a crazy way to phrase
it and compromise to a permanent end
Osama b l we got him now can you play
John C doing Mandarin and then I swear
I'll
finish I love John Cena moments the one
where he's talking about ice cream or
something did I heard that um J shett
put out
[Music]
a did you guys see is this not the one
that we're talking about no this is not
the apology I think hold on did you guys
see that one with Jay shedy where he put
He put out a video on Tik Tok about
Osama I don't know about that I swear I
remember maybe I'm misremembering but I
could have he could he was like this
just blew my mind changed everything he
right shut the [__] up that didn't
happen I I'm not 100% sure but I have
some kind of memory of him saying that
get out of here don't [__] be smirch
Shetty like that he says yeah man he was
right on about the Jew disgusting he
would never I think he said he was right
on about the Jews but I don't remember
Ethan's lying uh is this not the video
May misremembering is this the video
that you want he's apologizing over
Taiwan comment that's AP being shling
that's not the apology though wait what
did I say he apologizes to Taiwan
yeah this is so [__] iconic is it
this yeah that one's good and former pro
wrestler John
Cena go back I want to read the
subtitles John Cena's getting absolutely
[__] Hello China this is John
Cena wrong said Taiwan is a country
wrong wrong wrong not only is Taiwan not
a country also a bunch of losers that
you guys should totally colonize not
even a real place he it's not even a
real place it's like
zootopia St this is like a joke oh why
am I reading this go back God damn it
this like so terrible oh wait because it
was crazy though it it's
not it wasn't that off from what he
actually said you're just a guardian you
[__] okay here we go here we
I have to say right now in Fast and
Furious n this is not real is it is he
talking about this is what is happening
John little he says in one of them I
made a mistake during a promotional
interview everyone asked me if I can use
Chinese people at Fast and Furious n
inform information gave me interview
information I made a
mistake I have to say right now is so so
so so so
important I love and respect China and
the Chinese
people I'm so so sorry for my
mistake I'm so very sorry you have to
understand
I I love and respect China and Chinese
people I'm so sorry this man literally
just he like accidentally referred to
Taiwan as a country or something or just
you know flippantly because I mean it is
pretty much you know give me a [__]
break but there it is apparently you
can't say
that I'm so impressed by his Mandarin
though it's very impressive I got to get
him over to to you uan is that my
spot my yeah uhan that was the Jade
mining uh Province I need to meet him in
uhan start my new life all right this is
a this is longer than I thought we're
having too much fun out here um thanks
everyone for watching Love appreciation
and Good Vibes to everybody watching
right now um and have a wonderful night
today is it's Wednesday so we'll be back
on Friday for another great episode and
we'll do ill Pits on Friday I
promise yeah so one more thing I want to
say before I go last night we let the
rler talk even was geted up by baby gr
she said that
was
even hitting the gritty a grim is
shaking
fornite a grim is shaking
fornite